sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
Ihnen einen wunderschönen Tag die
Sitzung ist
eröffnet bevor wir beginnen begrüße ich
zwei neue Kolleginnen und einen Kollegen
in unserer Mitte für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten Armin Schwarz hat die
kollegenin Bettina Margarete Wiesmann
die Mitgliedschaft im deutschen
Bundestag
erworben herzlich
willkommen für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten kW mansuri rückt der
Kollege Martin Rabanus nach herzlich
willkommen
und für den ausgeschiedenen Abgeordneten
Timon gremmels hat die Kollegin Nadin
Ruf die Mitgliedschaft im deutschen
Bundestag erworben herzlich
willkommen ich komme nun zur
Tagesordnung interfraktionell wurde
vereinbart am Freitag im Anschluss an
die Haushaltsberatungen die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ältestenrates
zur Anerkennung und Rechtstellung der
Gruppe die Linke und der Gruppe bsw
sowie einen Antrag zu den
Mitgliederzahlen in den Ausschüssen in
verbundener Beratung
aufzusetzen ich sehe dazu keinen
Widerspruch dann können wir so verfahren
wir setzen nun die Haushaltsberatung
fort ich rufe auf den Einzelplan 04
Bundeskanzler und Bundeskanzleramt mit
den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
8604 und
8661 Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Otto Frie Denise
Andreas audr Markus Bühl und dr Gesine
löch Sowi den Einzelplan 22 unabhängiger
Kontrollrat mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
8661 und
8662 Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Franziska hoppermann Martin
Gerster Senn Christian Kindler Torsten
Herbst Wolfgang wiele und dr gesene
lösch wir werden später über den
Einzelplan 04 namentlich abstimmen für
die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 210
Minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
Aussprache und zuerst hat das Wort für
die CDU CSU Fraktion Friedrich
merärz frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es fällt
einigermaßen schwer nach dieser
Gedenkstunde heute morgen jetzt ganz
einfach zur Tagesordnung
überzugehen vielleicht darf ich damit
beginnen dass ich Ihnen Frau Präsidentin
aber auch unseren beiden Gästen die
heute morgen hier gesprochen haben Eva
cepesi und Marcel Reif noch einmal sehr
herzlich Dank sage für die bewegenden
Worte die sie gesprochen haben
und ich möchte ein weiteres Wort des
Dankes hinzufügen am Montag der letzten
Woche hat der französische
Staatspräsident Emmanuel macron von
dieser Stelle aus und zu Ehren unseres
verstorbenen Kollegen Wolfgang schuple
eine ich finde das darf man auch heute
noch einmal sagen eine wirklich große
Rede gehalten
Emmanuel macron hat uns Deutschen erneut
die Hand sehr weit ausgestreckt er hat
uns in seiner Rede geradezu
aufgefordert zusammen mit seinem Land
zusammen mit Frankreich
Führungsverantwortung in und für Europa
zu übernehmen
und ein Blick auf die aktuelle Lage in
der Welt ein Blick auf die Krisen und
die Kriege mit denen wir nun auch in das
Jahr 2024 hineingehen zeigt uns
Deutschland sollte ja Deutschland muss
diese ausgestreckte Hand des
französischen Staatspräsidenten jetzt
ergreifen Deutschland
muss gemeinsam mit Frankreich neue
Initiativen erarbeiten um die
Handlungsfähigkeit Europas unter Beweis
zu stellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte uns daran erinnern
dass die letzte große deutsche
Initiative für Europa aus dem Jahre
1989 stammt also heute schon mehr als 35
Jahre alt ist im Zuge der
Wiedervereinigung unseres Landes legte
der damalige Außenminister hansdiedrich
Genscher abgestimmt mit Frankreich ein
währungspolitisches Memorandum vor aus
dem dann gut 10 Jahre später die
Währungsunion wurde die letzte große
industriepolitische Initiative für
Europa die aus Deutschland kam liegt
mittlerweile fast 60 Jahre zurück es war
im Jahr
1965 die Gründung der
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Airbus so hieß sie
damals zwischen Deutschland aus Frank
und Frankreich aus der dann wie wir alle
wissen der größte europäische Luft und
raumfahrtkonzern
wurde ich nenne diese Beispiel weil sie
zeigen die Zeit ist mehr als reif für
Vorschläge in ähnlicher Dimension und
mit vergleichbarer
Tragweite Vorschläge die vor allem von
Deutschland und Frankreich auf den Weg
gebracht werden
müssen und erlauben Sie mir dass ich
hinzufüge das wären auch Vorschläge dies
Europäer vorbereiten auf einen möglichen
Wechsel im Weißen Haus in Washington ich
will zwei sehr konkrete Beispiele nennen
was früher die Währungspolitik war muss
heute im Interesse Europas die Außen und
die Sicherheitspolitik sein Deutschland
und Frankreich müssen enger
zusammenarbeiten und auf dem Weg hin zu
einer gemeinsamen europäischen
Verteidigungspolitik so früh wie möglich
andere Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen
Union mit ein beziehen nach dem
Regierungswechsel in Polen vor allem die
neue polnische Regierung diese
gemeinsame Verteidigungspolitik meine
Damen und Herren muss von Anfang an die
Rüstungspolitik die Beschaffung und die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
beinhalten und was früher was früher die
Luft und Raumfahrtindustrie war müssen
heute die Unternehmen der digital
Wirtschaft der Telekommunikation und die
Banken sein Deutschland und Frankreich
sollten so bald wie möglich
Verabredungen darüber treffen wie denn
in diesen und anderen Sektoren wirklich
europäische weltweit wettbewerbsfähige
Unternehmen entstehen
könnten dazu muss das europäische
Kartellrecht geändert werden denn der
sogenannte relevante Markt für diese
Unternehmen ist längst nicht mehr allein
Europa oder schon gar nicht der einzelne
Mitgliedstaat Staat sondern der globale
Markt auf dem europäische Unternehmen
wettbewerbsfähig sein müssen meine Damen
und Herren zu allen diesen strategischen
Fragen zu dieser strategischen
Neuausrichtung Europas sollte das Format
des Weimarer Dreiecks wiederbelebt
werden am besten mit einer sehr bald
ausgesprochenen Einladung der deutschen
Bundesregierung nach Weimar um von dort
aus den Weg hin zu einer gemeinsamen
europäischen Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik und auch hin zu einer
gemeinsamen europäischen
industrieppolitik zu
beschreiten
Deutschland Deutschland sollte diese
Aufgabe ein aus einer Position der
Stärke und der Verantwortung zugleich
übernehmen voraussetzung dafür ist dass
Deutschland seine Wachstumsschwäche
überwindet diese Wachstumsschwäche meine
Damen und
Herren hat ganz überwiegend strukturelle
Gründe und hängt zusammen mit
Standortbedingungen die in mehrfacher
Hinsicht unzureich sind ich will es auf
einen ganz einfachen Nenner bringen die
Arbeitskosten in Deutschland sind zu
hoch die Bürokratielasten werden immer
drückender die Energieversorgung ist zu
einseitig auf Wind und Sonne
ausgerichtet und die Steuerlast der
Unternehmen ist im internationalen
Vergleich ebenfalls zu
hoch Spielräume Spielräume in den
öffentlichen Haushalten lassen sich
erzielen
wenn Sozialleistungen unseres Landes auf
die konzentriert werden die sie wirklich
brauchen wenn die Lohnzusatzkosten
wieder bei 40% gedeckelt werden und wenn
die gesamte Last der Transformation hin
zur Klimaneutralität unserer
Volkswirtschaft nicht allein über
Subventionen aus den staatlichen
Haushalten finanziert
wird lassen Sie mich das etwas konkreter
machen wir sollten in Zukunft in der
Sozialpolitik unterscheiden zwischen
beitragsfinanzierten
Lohnersatzleistungen und
steuerfinanzierten
Sozialleistungen Lohnersatzleistungen
für die die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer Beiträge gezahlt haben
dienen der Überbrückung einer begrenzten
Zeit der Arbeitslosigkeit bei
gleichzeitigem Erhalt des
Lebensstandards steuerfinanzierte
Sozialleistungen dienen der Gewährung
des Existenzminimums und eines Minimums
einer sozialen Teilhabe und nur wenn
zwischen Arbeitseinkommen und
Sozialleistungen ein hinreichend großer
Abstand besteht wird die
Leistungsbereitschaft der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer auch
hinreichend belohnt meine Damen und
Herren
deshalb deshalb ist das System
Bürgergeld das genaue Gegenteil von dem
was wir jetzt brauchen um diese
Leistungsbereitschaft unser
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
wieder zu
fördern und meine Damen und Herren
dieser Befund wird durch empirische
Erhebungen bestätigt wenn die
Sozialpolitik so schreibt Renate Köcher
in der letzten Woche in ihrer
monatlichen Erhebung wenn die
Sozialpolitik zu einer Annäherung von
unterstützungs und Erwerbseinkommen
führt verliert sie an Vertrauen und
Unterstützung und zwar besonders in der
Mittelschicht und in den schwächeren
sozialen Schichten meine Damen und
Herren gerade von der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei Deutschlands
sie waren sie waren einmal die Partei
der ArbeiterInnen und Arbeit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
sind heute eine Partei der
subventionierten Arbeitslosigkeit
geworden und nicht mehr eine Partei der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und
wir sehen in unserem Land die gleichen
Fehlsteuerungen in einer Energie und
Klimapolitik die vor allem auf
umfangreiche Förderprogramme und auf
staatliche Subventionen setzt der Weg
hin zu einer klimaneutralen
Volkswirtschaft und zu der dafür
benötigten Infrastruktur lässt sich
nicht allein über öffentliche Haushalte
beschreiten dieses
Land unser Land meine Damen und Herren
braucht mutige aber realistische Ziele
unser Land wird den Wettbewerb auf der
Welt nur gewinnen wenn wir aufhören alle
anderen zu belehren und immer wieder
einen Sonderweg zu
suchen wir
brauchen wir brauchen
Wirkungsmechanismen über den Preis wie
mit der Bepreisung des
schadstoffausschusses und wir brauchen
in erheblichem Umfang wir brauchen in
erheblichem Umfang privates Kapital für
den Ausbau der Infrastruktur
insbesondere des benötigten
Leitungsnetzes und meine Damen und
Herren das alles ob sie das nun wollen
oder nicht geht nicht ohne einen ja die
Zwischenrufe zeigen ja dass ich sie
genau an der Stelle erreiche wo Sie
einfach die größte Schwäche haben in
ihrer gesamten
Argumentation meine Damen und Herren das
alles was ich hier gerade
beschreibe ohne einen tieferen und einen
breiteren europäischen Kapitalmarkt und
auch dazu wird Frankreich zusammen mit
uns und anderen ohne Zweifel bereit sein
nun werden sie und ich höre es an ihren
Zwischenrufen spätestens an dieser
Stelle fragen was diese Themen denn mit
ihrer Koalition und ihrem heute hier zur
Abstimmung gestellten Bundeshaushalt zu
tun haben ich will Ihnen die Antwort
geben gar nichts gar nichts sie haben
gar nichts damit zu tun wir sind wir
sind nämlich meine Damen und
Herren wir sind nämlich in allen
wesentlichen Fragen der außen und
Sicherheitspolitik der Wirtschafts und
Finanzpolitik der Arbeitsmarktpolitik
der innen und Rechtspolitik und nicht
zuletzt der Asyl und
Einwanderungspolitik vollkommen anderer
Meinung als sie und zwar nicht im Grund
nicht im Detail sondern im Grundsatz im
grundsätzlich und das ist ganz
einfach
das ist ganz einfach der Grund dafür
dass wir darauf verzichtet haben in den
Haushaltsberatungen irgendwelche
Änderungsanträge zu stellen ja meine
Damen und Herren wir wissen doch wie das
geht wir stellen die Anträge sie lehnen
alle Anträge ab Sie addieren die Summen
unserer Anträge und halten uns dann hier
im Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum vor wir
hätten noch höhere Ausgaben
vorgeschlagen das ist doch genau der
Wirkungsmechanismus den wir von ihnen
immer wieder hören wenn sie so nicht
verstehen dann will ich es ihnen
etwasopper sagen wenn sie nein meine
Damen und Herren wenn Sie die Jacke
unten falsch einknöpfen dann diskutieren
wir nicht mit ihnen wie groß denn der
Knopf oben im letzten Loch sein sollte
diese Diskussion führen wir mit ihnen
nicht ganz einfach im
übrigen im
übrigen wir haben wir haben in den
Letten
jren wieder und so gut wie in jeder
Sitzungswoche unsere Vorstellungen und
unsere Änderungsanträge hier im
Deutschen Bundestag eingebracht sie
haben bis zum heutigen Tag
ausnahmslos all samt abgelehnt damit
hier kein Missverständnis entsteht das
ist Dir gutes Recht sie haben hier zur
Zeit die Mehrheit aber bitte ersparen
sie sich und uns doch in Zukunft ihre
Aufrufe zur Zusammenarbeit diese Aufrufe
sind nichts anderes als reine politische
retorik sparen Sie sich und uns die
Zeit und wenn sie es noch etwas genauer
haben wollen da wo wir Sie bitten wie in
der vorletzten Woche geschehen doch
einmal inne zu halten und die Tragweite
ihrer Entscheidungen noch einmal zu
überdenken machen sie von ihrer Mehrheit
hier im Haus
kaltschneäuzig und rücksichtslos
gebraucht wie z.B beim
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht oder wie wieder
in dieser Woche beim Wahlrecht meine
Damen und Herren und den deutschlandpakt
Migration den haben wir nicht gekündigt
den haben sie
aufgekündigt die
Erfahrungen die Erfahrungen der letzten
zwei
Jahre zeigen dass sie an einer
wirklichen Zusammenarbeit bis mit uns
nicht wirklich und ernsthaft
interessiert sind im gegen
da wo wir Ihnen wie beim Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr zugestimmt haben halten Sie
sich anschließend nicht an die mit ihnen
verabredeten
Vereinbarungen und
deshalb und deshalb meine Damen und
Herren sind wir auch sehr zurückhaltend
sehr zurückhaltend wenn es um weitere
Änderungen des Grundgesetzes geht ich
stelle Ihnen eine Zustimmung dazu heute
grundsätzlich nicht in Aussicht und ich
schließe eine Zustimmung meiner Fraktion
zu einer Aufweichung der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes heute von dieser
Stelle aus hier erneut aus damit können
sie nicht
rechnen wir sagen stattdessen unserer
Bevölkerung die Aufgaben vor denen wir
stehen lassen sich lösen auch ohne
zusätzliche Abgaben und ohne neue
Schuld dazu müssen allerdings die
Prioritäten der Staatsausgaben neu
geordnet werden und meine Damen und
Herren ja ich tue das von dieser Stelle
aus noch vor der Sicherung unseres
Wohlstandes muss die Bewahrung unserer
Freiheit gegen alle Angriffe von innen
und von außen die absolute Priorität
haben nur in Freiheit lässt sich der
Friede sichern nur in Freiheit wird
Ukraine überleben und nur in Freiheit
kommt auch der Staat Israel hoffentlich
eines Tages wieder zur Ruhe
Freiheit Freiheit und vor allem
Meinungsfreiheit und
Religionsfreiheit sind auch die
Voraussetzungen für den inneren Frieden
in unserem Land dafür gehen die Menschen
in diesen Wochen in vielen h Städten zu
Tausenden in Deutschland auf die Straße
vor allem um gegen Rechtsradikalismus
und Rechtspopulismus zu demonstrieren ja
dass sie dabei nervös werden kann ich
gut verstehen wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich denn das Treffen der AFD
und anderer Rechtsextremisten in der
Villa Adlon in Potzdam hat offenbar doch
einer größeren Zahl von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern über den wahren Charakter dieser
Partei und ihrer Funktionäre die Augen
geöffnet meine Damen und Herren
das
Erstarken das Erstarken und das
Anwachsen des Rechtsradikalismus in
Deutschland besorgt uns wie viele andere
hier im Haus und im Land insgesamt
wirklich sehr aber wir sollten weniger
Zeit mit Abscheu und Empörung verbringen
als vielmehr nach den tieferen Gründen
zu suchen warum wir in der Lage sind
denn meine Damen und Herren die
Wählerinnen und Wähler der AFD sind
nicht alle
rechtsradikal aber sie sind alle
ziemlich
frustriert machen wir ein kurzes
Gedankenspiel stellen wir uns doch mal
einen kurzen Augenblick vor wir hätten
in Deutschland eine Regierung die
wenigstens die Ansprüche sind gar nicht
so hoch mittelmäßig gut regieren würde
und die im und die im langjährigen
Mittel in unserer Bevölkerung halbwegs
angesehen und respektiert wäre kann sich
irgendjemand hier im Haus vorstellen
dass die AFD unter solchen Umständen
innerhalb von 2 Jahren von 10 auf 20% in
Deutschland ange wachsen wäre meine
Damen und Herren das glauben vermutlich
doch noch nicht einmal sie von den
ampelfraktion die
Lösung die Lösung des Problems besteht
also offensichtlich darin dass sie die
dass sie die Probleme unseres Landes
lösen dafür sind sind sie gewählt und
dafür sitzen sie in der Regierung meine
Damen und Herren aber von einer Lösung
der Probleme in Deutschland sind sie zu
Beginn des Jahres
2024 noch weiter entfernt als zum Ende
des Jahres 2023 vor allem sie kommen die
sie bekommen die flüchtlingskrise nicht
in den Griff die
Umsetzung die Umsetzung der Beschlüsse
mit den Ministerpräsidenten verläuft Z
und träge ich gebe ihn ein Beel zum bei
der Einführung der Bezahlkarte meine
Damen und Herren die vor allem die vor
allem an dem systematischen Widerstand
von SPD und Grünen in Deutschland
scheitert da wo sie da wo sie eingeführt
wurde da wo sie eingeführt wurde nämlich
in einigen Landkreisen auf Initiative
der dortigen landträte sinkt die Zahl
der Asylbewerber über Nacht weil einer
der wesentlichen
aufenthaltsgründe nämlich der Bezug von
Bargeld plötzlich nicht mehr möglich ist
meine Damen und Herren so könnte es in
ganz Deutschland gehen wenn sie sich an
die Verabredungen halten würden die sie
mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten des ganzen Landes
mit allen 16 Ministerpräsidenten
geschlossen haben lassen Sie mich in
diesem Zusammenhang zur Klarstellung
aber für unsere Bundestagsfraktion und
auch für die sie beiden tragenden
Parteien hier noch einmal folgendes und
sehr unm
sagen mit uns gibt es keine Rückkehr zum
Nationalismus in Europa die Europäische
Union hat ihre Stärken und ihre
Schwächen aber sie ist vor allem die
Grundlage für Freiheit Frieden und
Wohlstand auf unserem Kontinent gerade
in Deutschland wir werden nicht zulassen
dass diese Grundlage zerstört wird meine
Damen und Herren
und wir stehen wir stehen zur
transatlantischen wirehen atlantischen
Partnerschaft Putins Russland ist kein
Partner für uns sondern der Feind auch
unserer Freiheit keiner politischen
Gruppierung keiner politischen
Gruppierung wie diese fundamentalen
Überzeugungen in Frage stellt werden wir
unsere Hand reichen an diesen
Überzeugungen endet jeder Kompromiss
meine Damen und Herren und ein letztes
Wort zu
Ihnen D und Herren von der sogenannten
Alternative für Deutschland sie haben in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen ihr wahres
Gesicht gezeigt sie machen gezielt und
seit langer Zeit geplant gemeinsame
Sache mit mit Rechtsextremisten jedweder
Herkunft ihre Netzwerke umfassen ihre
Netzwerke umfassen identitäre Bewegungen
genauso wie sogenannte Reichsbürger
sogenannte Reichsbürger meine Damen und
Herren Fremdenfeindlichkeit
Antisemitismus und Nationalismus muss
gehen bei ihnen Hand in Hand ebenso wie
enge Beziehungen zu Russland und ein
tief sitzender antiamerikanischer
Komplex unsere Botschaft an sie die sie
da drüben ganz rechts sitzen ist klar
und eindeutig genug ist genug sie sind
sie sind sie sind nicht die sie sind
nicht die Alternative für Deutschland
sie wären der endgültige Abstieg für
Deutschland und zwar gar nicht mal nur
wirtschaftlich sondern vor allem
moralisch und diesem Abstieg meine Damen
und Herren werden wir uns mit aller
Kraft die uns zur Verfügung stellt
entgegenstellen das Spiel bei ihnen geht
jetzt zu Ende herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
als nächster hat das Wort der
Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren Kollegen eva schppessi hat es uns
eben gesagt wer schweigt macht sich
mitschuldig
die
Gedenkveranstaltung sie hat uns alle
nachdrücklich beeindruckt aber sie hat
uns auch einen Auftrag mitgegeben dass
wir jetzt nicht schweigen wenn in diesem
Land Konferenzen stattfinden in
Landhäusern wo darüber beraten wird wie
ein Teil der Bevölkerung aus diesem Land
herausgebracht werden kann Remigration
als Stichwort das erinnert an die
dunkelsten Zeiten der deutschen
Geschichte und das ist nicht nur ein
Wort wie dann einige verhamlosen
versuchen sich das zurechtzulegen was
dort von ihnen selber diskutiert und
gesagt wird und von ihren Mitarbeitern
mitgeplant wird wir wissen dass es in
Landtagen jetzt von der AFD beantragt
wird und deshalb bin ich sehr froh
darüber dass so viele bürgerinen und
Bürger über alle Parteigrenzen Weg auch
solche die sich überhaupt nicht
parteipolitisch verorden gemeinsam in
Deutschlands Straßen zusammenkommen in
Kundgebung und für die Demokratie für
unser Grundgesetz und gegen das
Vergessen
demonstrieren und das ist mir an dieser
Stelle auch ganz wichtig weil mir immer
wieder und viel zu oft jetzt Bürger und
Bürger unseres Landes Staatsangehörige
Frauen und Männer die seit Jahrzehnten
hier leben die ihren Kinder hier groß
geworden sind erzählen dass sie Angst
haben ob sie gemeint sind ob sie jetzt
das Land verlassen müssen und deshalb
finde ich braucht es an dieser Stelle
auch ein ganz klares Bekenntnis von uns
allen wir stehen vor diesen Bürgern und
Bürgern sie müssen sich nicht fürchten
die Demokratie beschützt uns wie Eva
sheppessi es heute gesagt
hat
ich glaube dass es deshalb auch wichtig
ist dass wir anständig sind im Umgang
miteinander und dass
wir lachen Sie über sich selber Anstand
ist ja jetzt nicht das
kernkompetenzanliegen der
AFD auch darum dass wir auch dann klar
machen worum es hier geht um
rechtsextreme Ansichten die wir nicht
akzeptieren können und deshalb finde ich
es immer immer Herr märz ein kleines
Karo wenn in dieser Situation dann
jeweils auf den anderen gezeigt wird was
die Verantwortung dafür betrifft wir
müssen als Demokraten
zusammenstehen und es
wird und es wird der großen
Herausforderung nicht gerecht die wir
sehen wenn der rechte Populismus in den
USA so viel Unterstützung bekommt wenn
wir gesehen haben dass er Großbritannien
in ein ökonomisches Unglück gestürzt hat
mit dem brexit und wenn wir sehr klar
sehen dass so viele Regierungen in
Europa von Rechtspopulisten getragen
werden dass sie manchmal dabei sind wir
haben in Deutschland eine Aufgabe für
unser Geschichte wir wollen als
Demokratin und Demokraten zeigen dass
wir diesen Trend stoppen und zwar
gemeinsam
und es ist ja alles gesagt das finde ich
gehört doch zur Wahrheit dazu es ist
alles gesagt man soll alle wörtlich
nehmen auch die AFD sie meint was man
ihr unterstellt und zwar das Schlimme
und das ist glaube ich wirklich die
Wahrheit mit der wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen plötzlich fällt
so ein Wort wie dexit und das ist die
größte Wohlstands Vernichtung die für
Europa und für Deutschland passieren
könnte unser Land hat wie kein anderes
profitiert von der Europäischen Union
und der Zusammenarbeit
dort und deshalb her märz kann ich ihn
versichern
Emmanuel macron und ich sind verabredet
sehr sorgfältig
sehr sehr sorgfältig wie wir im
Einzelnen reagieren auf die möglichen
politischen Entwicklungen die in der
Welt auf uns zukommen und auch für alle
muss klar sein wenn die Welt noch
schwieriger wird auch z.B durch das was
an Wahlen in den USA Ergebnis als we
Ergebnis möglich ist dann muss die
Europäische Union umso stärker werden
und Frankreich und Deutschland müssen
diese Aufgabe wahrnehmen dass das auch
tatsächlich möglich
wird
und natürlich zählt dazu dass wir immer
im Blick haben dass Europa das stärkste
nationale Interesse ist das wir haben
und das hat dann viele viele
Konsequenzen aber zu denen zählt auch
dass es manchmal nicht gut ist die
Politik eine Zeit lang nicht so wor
sorgfältig verfeucht zu haben wenn immer
die Beispiele wo es irgendwie noch was
war sehr sehr lange zurückliegen aber
ich finde
das ist doch eine gute Zusammenarbeit
war die ich auch mit Frau Merkel hatte
als wir mit der französischen Regierung
gemeinsam dafür gesorgt haben dass es
möglich ist auf die coronakrise zu
reagieren mit einem europäischen
wiederaufbaufond die letzte große
europäische Initiative liegt nicht lange
zurück nur ihre Beteiligung an diesem
politischen Geschehnissen die liegt
lange zurück und ich finde man muss dann
auch einmal stolz sein auf das was eine
eigene Regierungschefin zustande
gebracht hat es war richtig was wir dort
gemacht haben Herr März vergessen Sie es
nicht reden sie nicht drüber hinweg es
war eine cdukanzlerin mit der mir das
gemeinsam gelungen
ist im übrigen im übrigen sind wir dabei
all das
aufzuarbeiten was in diesem Land liegen
geblieben ist und es ist sehr viel
liegen geblieben über viele Jahre über
sehr sehr sehr viele Jahre sind die
entscheidenden Weichen nicht gestellt
worden damit Deutschland eine
industrielle Zukunft haben kann und
deshalb deshalb Herr März war ihre Frage
berechtigt was hat eigentlich diese Rede
von ihnen mit dem gegenwärtigen Haushalt
und der gegenwärtigen Lage zu tun nichts
da haben sie recht aber die Frage muss
man
erweitern wasent
ihrch Zukunft Deutschlands zu tun nichts
das ist die Antwort die wir darauf geben
müssen und nachdem sie wirklich im
Untergrundkampf und intensiv dafür
gesorgt haben dass es keinen Ausbau der
Netze in Deutschland gibt nachdem sie
als CDU CSU Verantwortung dafür haben
dass der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energie
nicht vorangekommen ist nachdem sie
nichts geschafft haben für die
Erschaffung einer wasserstoffindust
strur für Deutsch nachdem sie es nicht
hingekriegt haben dass Investition in
der Stahlindustrie in der
Halbleiterindustrie in den
batteriefabriken in Deutschland
stattfinden finden alle diese Dinge
jetzt statt z Jahre haben Tempo gemacht
wo Tempo notwendig
war und wenn wir
und wenn wir genau hingehört haben bei
dem was Sie gesagt haben dann haben sie
ja gar nichts gelernt all die
Wachstumsbremsen die sie für Deutschland
gezogen haben die wollen sie
wiederziehen haben sie hier angekündigt
wie kann man so die Zukunft Deutschlands
verspielen wollen wie sie das tun
ökonomischer Sachverstand Null das ist
die Wahrheit keine Perspektive für
Deutschland keine industrielle
Perspektive keine Perspektive für die
Arbeitsplätze
und ich will ihn gerne ergänzen sie
reden damit das so klappt an all dem
vorbei was an Wirklichkeit über
Deutschland zu berichten ist und zu
dieser Wirklichkeit gehört in der Tat
dass wir zu kämpfen haben mit weltweiter
Wachstumsschwäche dass wir zu kämpfen
haben mit den Wachstumsbremsen der
Vergangenheit die wir gelöst haben dass
wir aber auch verzeichnen können
Deutschland hat den höchsten
Beschäftigungsstand in der Geschichte
den wir jemals verzeichnet haben noch
nie waren so viele Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer
erwerbstätig und wenn
sich wenn sich die Unternehmen in diesem
Lande vor etwas fürchten dann ist es
nicht wie vor 20 Jahren
Arbeitslosigkeit sondern dann ist es
arbeitskräftteangel das ist die
Herausforderung der Zukunft und diese
Regierung hat die Weichen dafür gestellt
dass wir etwas dagegen tun können mit
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz und mit
dem neuen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht all das ist
eine Perspektive für die Zukunft
Deutschland und darum haben wir dafür
gesorgt dass sich Arbeit in Deutschland
endlich wieder
lohnt mit dem Mindestlohn mit einem
Mindestlohn sie immer kämpfen weil wenn
sie dafür reden dass Arbeit sich lohnl
meinen sie 10 20 30 40% unserer
Arbeitsbevölkerung die viel zu wenig
verdien nie mit wir brauchen bessere
Löhne und der Mindestlohn war genau der
Weg das auf einen guten Kurs zu
bringen und das gleiche Geld für die
Frage der Einkommensverhältnisse
derjenigen die wenig verdienen wir haben
das gemacht mit den Dingen die wir als
Erleichterung für diejenigen die etwas
weniger als 2000 € verdienen gemacht
haben bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen mit dem
Wohngeld für Erwerbstätige und für
Renterin und Rentner mit der
Kindergelderhöhung und dem
Kinderzuschlag lauter Maßnahmen die das
Einkommen von Erwerbstätigen die leider
zu geringe Löhne haben verbessern wir
sind stolz auf diese gemeinsame
Leistung auch das gehört dazu mehrfach
Steuern gesenkt für Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer für Erwerbstätige die
selbstständig sind und nicht so große
Einkommen haben wir haben Steuern
gesenkt und die arbeitende Mitte dieses
Landes entlastet und ich sage ihn hier
diesen Kurs werden wir auch weiter
verfolgen es ist dabei gegen die
Zukunftsperspektive der Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer gegen diejenigen die jeden
Tag sich anstrengen wenn man ihnen dann
mitteilt das allerwichtigste was wir in
Deutschland machen wollen trotz stabiler
rentenfinanzen die wir gegenwärtig
verzeichnen können ist die Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters ergänzt noch durch
schöne laute reden über den Freizeitpark
Deutschland den wir angeblich bei der
großen Beschäftigungszahl die wir heute
haben ich finde diese Verunsicherung der
Lebensperspektive von Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmern die sie dort verbreiten
ist nicht in Ordnung und ich finde dass
es eine Beleidigung ist von fleißigen
Bürgern und Bürgern wenn man sagt sie
würden in einem Freizeitpark leben das
ist nicht in
Ordnung was soll die altväterliche
beschimppfung von Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmern die ihren Alltag zu
organisieren wollen mit alle müssen mal
mehr arbeiten sie arbeiten ganz schön
viel und ich finde solche Belehrung
haben sich die fleißigen dieses Landes
auch vom
Oppositionsführer nicht
verdient meine Damen und
Herren natürlich natürlich ist es
wichtig dass wir uns den Herausforderung
stellen die wir haben und eine davon ist
dass es angesprochen worden die
irreguläre
Migration und da haben
wir sehr viele sehr weitreich
Entscheidung getroffen übrigens im
größten Einvernehmen mit den 16 Ländern
dreimal haben wir uns mit ihnen
getroffen im letzten Jahr und haben alle
Fragen abgearbeitet und dreimal
gemeinsame Beschlüsse gefasst ein
endgültiger Finanzierungsmechanismus für
aufsteigende und absteigende zahlen wir
haben ganz konkrete Maßnahmen vereinbart
die der Bund machen muss und er hat sie
alle mit den Gesetzen die wir jetzt in
diesem Januar beschlossen haben
geliefert und auf wegb und wir arbeiten
daran dass es auch den Ländern gelingt
die Dinge voranzuingen die sie
übernommen haben kürzere Asylverfahren
schnellere Digitalisierung der
Ausländerbehörden und so weiter aber
wenn es dann so ist das ganz ohne ihr
Zutun die Länder mit dem Bund
vereinbaren dass wir eine Bezahlkarte
für
Asylbewerber einführen wenn jetzt die
Ausschreibung läuft und der
oppositionsbörer liest offenbar nicht
mal Zeitung und kann daraus berichten
dass das der Fall ist und links auf den
Weg dann ist irgendwas nicht richtig im
Lande der
Opposition ganz
offenbar lesen Sie nicht nur wenig
Zeitung sondern reden auch nicht mit den
CDU Ministerpräsidenten die hätten ihn
das so beim Bier mal nebenbei sagen
können das wäre eine gute Sache gewesen
übrigens mit dem intensivierten schutzs
mit dem Dingen die wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben gehen die Zahlen jetzt
auch zurück was die irreguläre Migration
betrifft und die Maßnahmen über die ich
eben geredet habe die sind ja alle jetzt
erst beschlossen werden gerade gesetzt
die kommen ja zudem noch dazu was jetzt
auch in der Realität in nächster Zeit
wirken wird und dazu zählt aus meiner
Sicht übrigens auch der jobturbo mit dem
wir dafür Sorge tragen dass die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge nachdem sie die
ganzen Kurse gemacht haben jetzt auch
aktiv in den Arbeitsmarkt vermittelt
werden mit wachsendem Erfolg und ich
finde übrigens auch dort ist es kein
Beitrag zur Solidarität mit der Ukraine
wenn der Oppositionsführer den hier
Schutz suchenden ukrainerinen und
Ukrainer mitteilt dass wir ihm so
entgegengekommen sind war wohl ein
Fehler das haben sie gemacht Herr mer
das haben sie
gemacht
aber ich will gerne einen Satz
hinzufügen ich habe ja bei dem einen
großen Thema ich will gleich noch drauf
kommen Tempo Tempo in Deutschland
versucht ein deutschlandpakt zustande zu
bringen und sie dazu zu bringen
mitzumachen was sie irgendwie nicht
richtig hingekriegt haben aber aber es
ist so dass sie dann sich ja auf ein
Teilthema kurzzeitig konzentriert hatten
Migration und wir hatten darüber auch
gute Gespräche jedenfalls Erinn ich mich
an keins davon schlecht wir hatten ein
gfältig und in diesem Gespräch in diesem
Gespräch habe ich ihn erläutert dass es
schon quasi über viele Fragen die ganz
wichtig sind eine Verständigung gibt mit
den Chefs der Senats und Staatskanzleien
und dass wir am folgenden Montag wir
trafen uns Freitag das wohl mit den
Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten vereinbaren werden
sie hatten überhaupt nichts dagegen
einzuwenden weil wir nämlich gesagt
haben darüber hinaus können wir ja noch
was machen und was erlebt die
öentlichkeit kaum ist diese Einigung mit
den Ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen erklärt der erklärt der
Oppositionsführer ja dann war's das wohl
mit der Zusammenarbeit in der Migration
so eine hasenfüßigkeit vor der eigenen
Verantwortung davon laufen das habe ich
noch nicht erlebt herrz so viel feikeit
vor der eenage habe ich noch nie
gesehen warum sie davon gelaufen sind
und ich glaube es lag daran dass sie das
schöne Thema nicht loswerden wollten wir
können alles geliefert haben alles kann
ordentlich gemacht sein wir kriegen das
in den Griff gemeinsam mit den Ländern
und den Kommunen in Deutschland was die
irreguläre Migration und ihr Managment
betrifft aber dann können sie ja nicht
mehr sagen alles läuft schief und darum
sind sie weggelaufen das ist der Grund
warum sie für ein Kompromiss nicht mehr
weiter zur Verfügung
überhaupt sind sie da ein ganz
besonderer Teilen jeden Tag gegen die
Bundesregierung aus ist ihr recht
ordentlich schwer unter die Gürtellinie
ist auch ihr Recht aber wenn sie dann
mal kritisiert werden dann sind sie eine
Mimose ich finde wer ein wer Box der
soll kein glaskin haben aber sie haben
ein ganz schönes Gaskin
Herr
meine Damen und
Herren wir haben eine große wir haben
eine große Herausforderung angesichts
des russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und der wird ja jetzt auch heute
Abend in Brüssel nach den
trauerfeierigkeiten für Jacques Delor
und morgen eine große Rolle spielen wir
müssen die Ukraine unterstützen in ihrem
Freiheitskampf um den es in der Tat geht
und es ist notwendig dass wir mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine nicht
nachlassen das ist unsere Verpflichtung
für den Frieden in Europa und für die
Sicherheit in
Europa es ist übrigens erstaunliches was
die Ukrainer Ukrainer geleistet haben
vergessen wir nicht wie viel von ihrem
Territorium von Russland schon erobert
war und wie viel sie auch wieder
zurückerobert haben vergessen wir nicht
mit welcher beharlichkeit Sie sich den
unglaublichen Ansturm russischer Truppen
wo der russische Präsident den Verlust
eigener Soldaten nicht scheut in
größeren Ordnung die man kaum
auszusprechen mag und wo er nicht scheut
Material einzusetzen und alles zerstören
zu lassen um das Ziel das er hat
tatsächlich zu erreichen nämlich ein
Teil oder die ganze Ukraine zu erobern
und er hat damit das in Frage gestellt
was will Brand und Helmut Schmidt auf
den Weg gebracht haben
mit KSZE und heutiger OSZE mit der
Friedens und sicherheitsordnung in
Europa die lautet mit Gewalt dürfen
keine Grenzen in Europa mehr verschoben
werden das muss unser Prinzip
sein in der ganzen Welt hat sich
rumgesprochen bald auch in Deutschland
wir sind der größte Unterstützer nach
den USA für die Ukraine auch was
militärische Unterstützung mit Waffen
betrifft und wir sind es mit dem
Haushalt über den wir hier beraten und
den plän für dieses Jahr auch in Europa
nach allem was wir wissen können es es
mehr als die Hälfte was aus Deutschland
geleistet werden wird in diesem Jahr für
diesen Widerstand der Ukraine und
deshalb sage ich hier an dieser Stelle
ist es mir ganz wichtig dass wir eine
breitere europäische Unterstützung
hinbekommen es kann nicht allein an
Deutschland hängen um noch einmal Helmut
Schmidt zu zitieren wir sind nur eine
Mittelmacht und wenn wir diejenigen
wären die das überwiegend machen müssen
dann ist es nicht genug für die Ukraine
wir wollen dass mehr Länder sich aktiv
beteiligen and der Unterstützung der
Ukraine auch mit Waffenlieferung auch
mit dem was sie dort
finanzieren ich sage das bewusst
nicht um andere
vorzuführen
deshalb haben wir das auch nicht getan
dass wir da einzelne
öffentlich angesprochen haben weil wir
wollen ja das Gegenteil wir wollen ja
das alle sagen okay wir strengen uns
noch einmal an und das hoffe ich wird
auch das Ergebnis der Beratung sein die
wir heute und morgen beginnen aber
sicherlich in dieser Frage nicht
abschließen werden nur das will ich hier
gerne versichern wir werden unseren
großen Beitrag für dieses Jahr leisten
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass der
gemeinsame Beitrag Europas so groß ist
dass die Ukraine darauf bauen kann und
dass Putin nicht darauf rechnen kann
dass unsere Unterstützung irgendwann
nachlässt das darf er nicht
denken ja ja es ist so wer hofft auf die
amerikanischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen der hofft auf das
ermüden in Europa
und wir wissen wie schwierig das ist
wenn wir in die USA gucken es wird ist
immer noch nicht gelungen dass der
amerikanische Präsident eine Zustimmung
im Kongress für seine Haushaltsmittel
bekommen hat die er für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine dieses Jahr
benötigt ich bin ganz zuversichtlich
dass er das schaffen
wird und wir werden alle unseren Beitrag
leisten mitzuhelfen zu überzeugen dass
das eine gemeinsame Sache für uns die
Freund der Freiheit der Demokratie und
des Rechtsstaats ist die Ukraine nicht
alleine zu
lassen aber man stelle sich einmal kurz
vor das gelingt nicht und dann wäre
Deutschland stand jetzt der größte
Unterstützer was Waffenlieferung
betrifft für die Ukraine
weltweit liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
das ist etwas wo wir international alles
dafür tun müssen dass dieser Zustand
nicht eintritt denn es wäre Hybris wenn
wir glaubt dass wir alleine es richten
können so ist es nicht wir brauchen
Gemeinsamkeit und Solidarität
übrigens gilt das auch für die anderen
Beschlüsse die jetzt in Europa notwendig
sind über den europäischen Haushalt den
wir jetzt endlich beschließen wollen und
in dem ist ja auch eine hausaltshilfe
für die Ukraine von 12 Milliarden Euro
pro Jahr für die nächsten Jahre
vorgesehen es geht also um sehr viel
Unterstützung die notwendig ist es geht
um ein zusammenstehen Europas in diesen
Zeiten und das will ich dann auch zum
Schluss im Hinblick auf unser
gemeinsames Europa sagen ja wir brauchen
eine gemeinsame Anstrengung dass Europa
vorankommt und wie ich es vielleicht für
den einen oder anderen überraschend
unbedingt auf ein SPD Parteitag gesagt
habe
wir brauchen die Banken und
kapitalmarktunion damit das vorangeht
und deshalb müssen wir aus dem was wir
schon geschafft haben eine weitere
Initiative entfalten die
Mindestbesteuerung die wir in Europa
etabliert haben könnte doch auch der
Maßstab sein für eine einheitliche
gemeinsame körperschaftsbasis
basiskörperschaftssteuer damit die
Banken europaweit unter fairen
Bedingungen Wettbewerb machen können das
wäre ein echter Fortschritt für Europa
und wir brauchen ihn dring
wir brauchen ih bringt denn tatsächlich
ist ein Teil des besseren
Wirtschaftswachstums der USA
zurückzuführen auf ihre Banken und
Kapitalmärkte die mehr in der Lage sind
das Wachstum der Wirtschaft ohne
öffentliche Subventionen zu begleiten
und groß zu investieren in Startups und
wachsende Unternehmen manchmal welche
die jahrelang trotz Milliarden Bewertung
keine Gewinne machen das ist etwas was
in Europa in gleicher Weise nicht
vorkommt und deshalb ist es unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe dass wir diesen
dieses Hindernis für Wachstum und
Wohlstand in Europa beseitigen und die
Tatsache dass es dieses Jahr so viel um
Europa gehen muss die ist vielleicht ein
Anlass an diesem und allen anderen
notwendigen Reformen für ein starkes
souveränes Europa in einer
globalisierten Welt zu arbeiten schönen
Dank
als nächster hat das Wort für die AFD
Fraktion dr Alice
Weidel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Herr Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die beiden Vorredner
haben eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass es
ihnen an Ernsthaftigkeit für die wahren
Belange und Probleme der Bürger in
diesem Lande
fehlt es
brennt es brennt in
Deutschland und diese Regierung aus
überforderten
Fehlbesetzung und starsinnigen Ideologen
ist ja Brandstifter die geschundenen
Leistungsträger dieses Landes gehen auf
die
Straße Bauern Handwerker Mittelständler
Gastwirte Händler
Transportunternehmer sie protestieren
weiter weil sie nicht mehr
können verschwiegen von den
Medien dreiviertel der deutschen stehen
hinter den
mittelstandsprotesten
Dreier sich ein Ende dieser
Regierung sie ziehen eine Schneise der
Verwüstung durch dieses
Land aber statt zu korrigieren setzen
Sie sich an die Spitze einer
beispiellosen der Kinderbuchautor sitzt
da Frau
esken setzen Sie sich an die Spitze
einer beispiellosen Verleumdungskampagne
wie gerade hier eindrucksfol geschildert
gegen die
mittelstandsproteste und gegen die
Oppositionskraft auf die immer mehr
Bürger ihre Hoffnung setzen frei nach
dem Motto wird der Bürger unangenehm
bezeichne ihn als
rechtsextrem ihre
hilfsstasi
Korrektiv eine der vielen
Nichtregierungsorganisation die von
ihrer Regierung mit reichlich Steuergeld
versorgt wird hat ihn dafür die Vorlage
geliefert mit unglaublichen Lügen
Verleumdung und übelster
Nachrede und die Chefin von
Korrektiv lügt jetzt ein vor sich hin
sie hätte das Wort Deportation nie
benutzt soweit ist es schon gekommen
steuerfinanzierte denonzination gegen
eine
konkurrenzpartei
sie schämen sich nicht einmal sie
schämen sich nicht einmal das
Demonstrationsrecht zu pervertieren ein
Freiheitsrecht der Bürger gegenüber dem
Staat und nicht umgekehrt statt den
Menschen zuzuhören die ihren not in die
Öffentlichkeit tragen demonstrieren sie
selbst gegen die Opposition und sie
finden auch nichts dabei wenn auf
solchen Demos ganz offen
Mordaufrufe gegen Oppositionspolitiker
zur Schau gestellt werden
afdler töten steht dort und sie
klatschen
Beifall der
Bundespräsident bezeichnet AFD Wähler
als Ratten und die FDP Spitzenkandidatin
AFD Wähler als Schmeißfliegen schämen
sie sich schämen sie sich in Grund und
Boden mit ihrer unsäglichen
steuerfinanzierten verdungs und Rufmord
spten Sie dieses Land und nur um sich an
ihre eigene Macht zu
klammern die Reparatur der Reparatur
eines missglücken und aufgeblähten
Haushaltsentwurfs ist ein Dokument ihrer
Arroganz und ihres Unvermögens sie reden
vom Sparen aber sie bürden die Lasten
allein den Bürgern auf die Stimmung bei
den Unternehmen ist am Boden die Ampel
ist das größte standortrisiko für
Deutschland mittelständische Unternehmen
werfen reinenweise das Handtuch und
ergreifen die Flucht die Liste der
Firmen die z000 Stellen streichen oder
ins Ausland verlagern wir täglich länger
klangvolle Namen sind darauf von brsf
Bayer um Bosch über kontinental Mercedes
und Miele bis SAP und
ZF industrialisierungsminister habck der
bekanntlich Vaterlandsliebe steht zum
kotzenfand fordert die Unternehmen nun
zum Patriotismus auf Pleite zu gehen das
ist das Konzept dieser Bundesregierung
Deutschland steckt tief in einer
rezzession als einziges Industrieland
schrumpft es und dafür trägt weder Putin
die Verantwortung noch die Welt noch
irgendeine herbei fantasierte
weltklimakatastrophe diese unfähige
Regierung trägt als einzige die anwung
für das Disaster in unserem
Land und zwar mit ihrer zerstörerischen
Politik der künstlichen
Energieverknappung und
energieverteuerung des unablässigen
Drehens an steuerschrauben der
Verbotspolitik der Enteignung der
Geldverschwendung während sie den Leuten
das Märchen vom reichen Land erzählen
reich ist in Deutschland nur der
überfütterte übergriffige Staat aber
nicht der
Steuerzahler erhalten in diesen Tagen
ihre
Heizkostenabrechnung und wissen oft
nicht wie sie sie bezahlen sollen
Normalverdiener Rentner Familien
Mittelständler Freiberufler müssen sich
Jahr für Jahr mehr einschränken um noch
über die Runden zu kommen sie selbst
aber denken gar nicht daran sich
einzuschränken sie gönnen sich neue
Hubschrauber und Fuhrparks ihre
Kabinettsmitglieder geben Unsummen für
Friseure und Fotografen aus die
Außenministerin fliegt mit großem Tross
in feinlichen Missionen weltweit während
der
Durchschnittsverdiener nicht weiß was er
sich überhaupt noch leisten kann und sie
halten an ihrem protzkanzleramt für fast
sage umschreibe 800 Millionen Euro fest
der gigantomanische
Erweiterungsbau kostet allein fast so
viel wie das jährliche Sonderopfer was
sie den bauernn abverlangen wollen sie
haben den
Beamtenapparat in nur um rund
1100 Stellen aufgebläht schön für ihre
Günstlinge schlecht für die Steuerzahler
den der ganze Spaß 8 Milliarden Euro
kostet wo andere Regierung ihr
internationales Engagement überdenken
und zurückfahren drängen sie sich
überall auf mit dem deutschen Steuergeld
die eigenen Bauern bedrohen sie in der
Existenz um eine knappe Milliarde zu
sparen aber für unsinnige agrarprojekte
in der Welt
geben sie weiter hunderte Millionen Euro
aus die vielziitierten Radwege in Peru
sind nur eines von hunderten
überflüssigen
Entwicklungshilfe Vorhaben die in der
Summe den Steuerzahler
3 Milliarden Euro kosten für nichts nur
für ihre NGO Günstlinge sie verpulvern
dieses Geld ohne Gegenleistung für
ökokühlschränke in Kolumbien
feministische Außenpolitik in Südafrika
für die Taliban in Afghanistan und für
Hamas Terroristen im Gaza selbst nach
Indien gehen Milliarden obwohl Indien
zum Mond fliegt während bei uns die
Infrastruktur zerfällt die Schulen
vergammeln und die Schüler teilweise
nicht mehr richtig lesen schreiben und
rechnen
können gegen die Gesetze der Physik und
der Logik treiben sie das
planwirtschafts und subvenstionsmonster
Energiewende weiter voran in der
energiepolik ist Deutschland der
Geisterfahrer der Welt die Kosten
sprengen alle Dimension sie sind der
Hauptgrund für die
Haushaltskrise sie summieren sich auf
fast eine Billion Euro seine eins mit
wie viel Nullen Herr habbeck wissen Sie
nicht das sind keine Investition in die
Zukunft das ist die teuerste Zerstörung
einer funktionierenden Infrastruktur die
die Welt je gesehen
hat und sie Flen das
landiter alen Migranten jeder kann
kommen keiner muss gehen sie Bürgern im
Akkord neue Wähler ein verschaffen
illegalen über das
chancenaufenthaltsrecht eine
scheinlegalität ihr
abschiebungsbeschleunigungsgesetz ist
ein
abschiebungsverhinderungsgesetz wenn der
Steuerzahler abgelehten Asylbewerbern
auch noch ein Anwalt bezahlen muss um
weiter gegen die überfällige Ausreise zu
prozessieren mit dieser Politik treiben
sie die Kommunen in die Verzweiflung
sprengen die Sozialsysteme verschärfen
die wohn
und untergraben die innere Sicherheit
aber vor allem sie nehmen den Deutschen
ihre Heimat
über 1000
Frauen werden jedes Jahr Opfer sexueller
Gewalt durch Zuwanderer 7000 seit dem
willkommensputsch der cdukanzlerin von
2015 aber darüber schweigen sie darüber
schweigen auch die Medien unter dem
schwindeletikett Bürgergeld haben sie
ein
migrationsmagneten geschaffen der dessen
Kosten längst außer Kontrolle sind das
nächste Haushaltsloch steht schon vor
der Tür sie lassen die Bürger im Stich
wo der Staat dringend gebraucht würde wo
bleibt die Entschädigung an die vielen
impfgeschädigten ihrer covidimpfung wo
bleibt die eigentlich wo bleibt
überhaupt die Aufarbeitung dieses ganzen
disasters wieder und wieder habe ich
hier aufgeführt was nötig ist um dieses
Land auf Vordermann zu bringen noch mal
und Kontrolle der Grenzen Zurückweisung
illegaler Einwanderer Rückführung
abgelehnter und krimineller Asylbewerber
und jener die kein Aufenthaltsrecht
haben das ist die Durchsetzung von Recht
und Gesetz nach Jahren des herschafts
des Unrechts sie wollen Abschiebung
kriminalisieren das haben wir gesehen in
ihrer
Kampagne Stopp der Energiewende
Beschränkung der Staatsausgaben und
natürlichichung des bürgerg für ische
Staatsbürger die nie in die Sozialkassen
eingezahlt haben sachstatt Geldleistung
ist die Devise aber rationale Argumente
erreichen sie schon gar nicht mehr sie
können Deutschland nicht gut regieren
und sie wollen es nicht sie richten es
zuug Grunde und ich sage ihn auch
warum weil sie ihr eigenes Land weil sie
Deutschland hassen diese Regierung HST
Deutschland sie wenigstens die
Möglichkeit eines demokratischen
Machtwechsels und machen sie den Weg
frei für Neuwahlen ich bedanke
mich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie recht herzlich genauso wie die Damen
und Herren auch den besuchertribünen und
wir fahren in der Debatte fort und die
nächste Rednerin ist für Bündnis neusig
die grün Britta
Hasselmann sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren
und heute sage ich mal einmal
ausnahmsweise sie liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auf den Tribünen und denen die am
Bildschirm vielleicht unsere Debatte
verfolgen wenn es eines Beweises bedurft
hätte warum es höchste Zeit ist dass in
Nordhausen Eckernförde
Altenburg Frankfurt sondhofen Zwickau
Hamburg bielefeld wninger rote Halle
Brandenburg Plauen gieen München
Regensburg füsten Worms wzenburg oder
wism oder Bautzen Menschen auf die
Straße gehen und sagen wir haben etwas
zu verteidigen nämlich nicht weniger als
unsere Demokratie unsere Freiheit und
unseren
Rechtsstaat dann die Rede von Alis
Weidel meine Damen und Herren
wie viel
Verachtung wie viel Verachtung wie viel
Menschenfeindlichkeit wie viel
Gefährlichkeit und wie viel
Verächtlichmachung demokratischer
Institutionen waren hier gerade in 10
Minuten zu hören meine Damen und Herren
es ist unglaublich eine
verunglipfung der Opfer des SED
regim durch unsägliche Vergleiche in
einem freien Land von einer freien
Presse
die geklärt hat und rausgekriegt hat wie
tief die Verstrickung von
Rechtsextremismus
identitärer Bewegung
AFD in sogenannten Geheimtreffen in
Potzdam war und der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden steht heute
wahrscheinlich das Wasser zum Hals weil
der zweite ihrer Mitarbeiter soll auch
in Potzdam gewesen sein ich wäre auch
nervös meine Damen und Herren wenn so
etwas passieren würde beim Geheimtreffen
war offenbar nicht nur ihr Roland
Hartwig sondern auch ein gewisser mürrig
der vom Bundesvorstand der AFD bezahlt
wird meine Damen und Herren es ist so
sie sind demokratisch gewählt diese AFD
Abgeordneten aber sie sind keine
Demokraten und das erkennen immer mehr
Menschen und deshalb braucht es die
inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung mit ihnen
sie führen dieses Land in ein rückwärts
in ein nie wieder was wir auf jeden Fall
verhindern werden als DemokratInnen und
Demokraten denn das sind wir Menschen
wie
evachi und Marcel Reifs Vater schuldig
sag ich stellvertretend nach einem einer
so würdigen Gedenkstunde wie heute
morgen in der Eva sepeschi uns
aufgefordert hat gemeinsam und sie alle
auch an ihrer Stelle zu sagen nie wieder
ist jetzt und Marcel Reif gesagt hat sei
ein Mensch wissen wir ganz genau als
DemokratInnen und Demokraten und zwar
von CDU CSU FDP Grünen und SPD was
unsere Arbeit ist nämlich diese
Demokratie zu verteidigen mit allem was
wir haben meine Damen und Herren gegen
die Feinde der Demokratie und ich weiß
dass sie nervös sind ich weiß dass ihnen
das Wasser bis zum Hall steht drei ihrer
Landesverbände in denen unter anderem
bald Wahlen sind sind als rechtsextrem
gesichert rechtsextrem eingestuft meine
Damen und Herren lassen Sie sich nicht
erzählen sie hätten Rezepte Lösungen und
Ideen für die Zukunft ein Ausstieg aus
der Europäischen Union ein Ausstieg aus
dem Euro würde
nationalverarmungen und eine die
Industrialisierung in diesem Land
bedeuten meine Damen und Herren und zwar
für alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger das muss
jede und jeder wissen der oder die mit
der AFD sympathisiert und ich kenne den
Bundes präsidenten ich schätze den
Bundespräsidenten und niemals wird er
über die Wählerinnen und Wähler auch
einer solchen Partei wie ihrer gesagt
haben es seien Ratten ich finde es
ungeheuerlich dass sie einen solchen
Vorwurf in diesem Haus erheben meine
Damen und Herren und ich erwarte dass
sie das Zurücknehmen denn Sie können es
durch nichts belegen sie schaden damit
dem Ansehen der demokratischen
Institution und das muss man aller
Klarheit zurückweisen meine Damen und
Herren weil die Lage aber so ist wie sie
ist meine ganz große
Bitte an Sie Herr März sie haben vorhin
gesagt sparen Sie sich Aufrufe zur
Zusammenarbeit nein das werde weder ich
tun noch die FDP Bündnis 90 die Grünen
noch die SPD denn wir wissen dass in
diesen Stunden DemokratInnen und
Demokraten aller demokratischen Parteien
gefordert sind und ich möchte dass sie
diese Haltung auch einnehmen denn die
Lage ist ernst in diesem Land wir sparen
uns diese Aufrufe zur Zusammenarbeit
nicht denn sie sind notwendig und machen
Sie sich doch nicht so klein wir haben
doch in diesem Haus auch schon gezeigt
dass es geht um die Demokratie
wehrhafter zu machen haben wir gemeinsam
das Parteienfinanzierung verändert meine
Damen und Herren unlautere Wahlwerbung
ihre ganzen
parteispendensümpfe sind so klarer
darlegbar meine Damen und Herren da
haben wir ein Riegel vorgeschoben
gemeinsam mit Ihnen Herr März wir haben
gerade das Stiftungsgesetz geändert
damit einfach klar ist wir haben erstmal
eins geschaffen was einen klaren
Rechtsrahmen gibt meine Damen und Herren
dafür dass Stiftung auf dem Grund und
Boden die dieser Verfassung stehen
müssen und das klar und deutlich
geregelt ist und zwar zusammen mit der
sie tragenden Bundestag Bundesregierung
und unseren Fraktionen und ihnen wir
haben das Disziplinarrecht geändert
damit rechtsextremen Umtrieben in
Polizei und Bundeswehr Einhalt geboten
wird also tun sie doch nicht so als
würden wir hier nicht zusammenarbeiten
und diese Zusammenarbeit ist auch
notwendig dringend notwendig in dieser
Zeit und sag ihn mal aus vielen
Gesprächen mit Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
ob bei der Kirche oder ihren CDU
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor Ort ich
weiß das ganz genau dass sie sich alle
wünschen dass DemokratInnen und
Demokraten jetzt zusammen stehen das tun
sie nämlich auch vor Ort in den Städten
in den Gemeinden und wir arbeiten in
sehr unterschiedlichen Konstellationen
als demokratische Kräfte in den Ländern
zusammen also treiben sie hier keinen
Spalt rein wo er nicht gebraucht wird
bzw gefährlich ist meine Damen und
Herren ich bedauere meine Damen und
Herren die Unsicherheit die nach dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht
entstanden ist was den Haushalt angeht
wir wissen sehr genau dass wir lange
gebraucht haben um das Urteil
auszuwerten und die Schlüsse daraus zu
Zehen die notwendig waren dass das in
Wirtschaft Industrie Handwerk bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch für
Verunsicherung gesorgt hat aber diese
Woche entscheiden wir in der Sache über
einen Haushalt und wir haben das
hingekriegt trotz aller
Unterschiedlichkeit in den Auffassungen
die vielleicht zwischen FDP Bündnis 90
die Grünen und SPD und auch in der
Bundesregierung existierten wir bringen
diese Woche einen Haushalt auf den Weg
der für Klarheit schafft und der einen
Rahmen gibt für die
Zukunftsinvestitionen die notwendig sind
für die soziale gerecht it und für die
Demokratie meine Damen und Herren und
das ist ein gutes Signal bei aller
Unterschiedlichkeit es verbindet uns
drei nämlich die Überzeugung auch wenn
es schwer war dass wir zusammen agieren
und dass wir hier gemeinsam für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die Industrie
für das Handwerk und vor allen Dingen
für die zentralen Zukunftsfragen die
Bekämpfung der Klimakrise die notwendige
Transformation also das heißt die
Veränderung die sozial und ökologische
die notwendig ist weil wir uns nach 16
Jahren Stillstand sowas nicht mehr
leisten können meine Damen und Herren es
braucht Veränderung das ist mittlerweile
bis tief in die großen
Wirtschaftsunternehmen klar die lächzen
danach dass wir die Rahmenbedingungen
setzen ein einfaches weiter so Herr März
wie in der 90er Jahre Wirtschaftspolitik
ist nicht die Zukunft unseres Landes die
führt uns nach unten im bleibt sie da
stehen aber das können wir nicht
gebrauchen wir haben viel zu viele
Herausforderungen und tun Sie mir noch
einen
Gefallen sozialer Zusammenhalt das
soziale Miteinander und auch die
Verantwortung dieses
Parlamentes für die sozialen Fragen und
die Sicherheit von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern beantwortet man nicht indem man
das Bürgergeld als subventionierte
Arbeitslosigkeit bezeichnet wissen Sie
eigentlich was sie Menschen gegenüber
damit machen das ist ein treten nach
unten eine Abwertung und das spüren
Menschen sie sollten das nicht tun denn
sie haben gemeinsam mit uns im Bundestag
und im Bundesrat mit allen Ländern
gemeinsam das Bürgergeld auf den Weg
gebracht und sich jetzt so billig aus
der Verantwortung zu schleichen das wird
doch Ihnen auch gar nicht gerecht in
ihrer Rolle mein
meine Damen und
Herren meine Damen und Herren sie tragen
Verantwortung wie wir für dieses
Bürgergeld für das Konzept weil sie
haben in beiden Kammern den Bundesrat
und dem Bundestag zugestimmt und ich
rate einfach nur dazu tun sie nicht das
Gleiche was andere versuchen durch die
Abwertung von Menschen andere in eine
bessere Lage zu versetzen oder Leute
gegeneinander auszuspielen Olaf Scholz
hat gerade in seiner Rede darauf
hingewiesen wo waren Sie denn wo waren
sie als wir über den Mindestlohn
gesprochen haben wo sind sie wenn es um
Tariftreue geht alle absicherungsfragen
die notwendig sind auch für die Zukunft
ich höre nichts von ihnen oder ist jetzt
Steffen kamppeter ihr neues altes
sprachhor der zu allem nur nein sagt
weil er in der Wirtschaftspolitik der
90er verhangen geblieben
gucken Sie sich den Aufruf der
Unternehmen der 50 die gerade sagen wir
haben eine Herausforderung es gibt kein
Stillstand oder zurück es gibt nur ein
nach vorn und wir brauchen die
Unterstützung dieser Bundesregierung und
dieses Parlamentes dafür notwendige
Investitionen anschübe für
Transformation auch wirklich stemmen zu
können niemand redet in diesen
Unternehmen davon dass wir sie auf Dauer
subventionieren soll das ist doch
völliger Quatsch sie brauchen
verlässliche Rahmenbedingungen sie
brauchen anschübe für
Zukunftsinvestitionen und das ist es was
Sie brauchen und J sparen diese billigen
Zwischenrufe gerne guckt dir doch gucken
Sie sich doch tüssenstahl in Essen an
tüssen in Essen an was ist denn mit dem
grünen Stahl reden Sie doch mal mit den
Leuten ich habe doch gerade schon gesagt
reden Sie nicht nur mit Kampeter sondern
gehen Sie in die Unternehmen und reden
mit denen
[Applaus]
die schütel mit dem KF wenn die ihre
wirtschaftspolitischen Vorstellungen
hören und T sie mir einen Gefallen reden
Sie dieses wunderbare Land nicht so
schlecht viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die ich gerade erlebe auf den
Straßen die wollen in diesem Land
leben
für Sie Freiheit bedeutet weil dieses
Land bedeutet hier sind sie aufgewachsen
geboren oder hierher gekommen weil sie
hier eine Arbeit gefunden haben und weil
sie hier ihre Familie gegründet haben
weil ihre Kinder hier zur Schule gehen
und die lieben dieses Land und im
Einzelfall wird es so sein dass der eine
oder die andere unter bestimmten Fragen
leidet oder unzufrieden ist und auch wir
können vieles besser machen da bin ich
überzeugt und wir müssen einiges besser
machen aber in dieser
plateit auf das was Menschen draußen von
uns erwarten in dieser Situation der
Demokratie so einfach und schlicht zu
antworten wird auch Ihnen nicht Gericht
wir sind alle zusammen gefordert
wirklich
gefordert unser Land Zukunft fest
zuachchen Sicherheit zu geben damit
diese notwendige
Veränderung auch gestaltet wir den kann
dass wir niemanden zurücklassen in
dieser Situation und wir sind
gemeinsam verantwortet diese Demokratie
und den Rahmen dafür auch gemeinsam
fester und resilienter zu machen
wehrhafter in unserer Demokratie und da
fordere ich Sie auf Herr März nehmen Sie
Ihren Eingangspunkt nicht so ernst dass
sie keine Zusammenarbeit wollen ich find
es wichtig wir alle geben als
demokratische Kräfte ein Signal aus dass
wir wissen was die Stunde geschlagen hat
und als DemokratInnen und Demokraten
nicht nur die Rede und Gegenrede suchen
sondern auch den Konsens denn der gehört
zu einer Demokratie
danke
[Musik]
und für die FDP Fraktion hat jetzt das
Wort Christian
dör herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
erleben gegenwärtig überall in
Deutschland Demonstration gegen
Rechtsextremismus mit beeindruckenden
Teilnehmerzahlen ich habe selbst an der
Demonstration in Bremen teilgenommen
dort habe ich
die dort habe ich die Breite bürgerliche
Mitte unserer Gesellschaft angetroffen
ganz normale Menschen die sich sorgen
unsere freiheitliche Demokratie machen
wir haben heute Vormittag hier im
Deutschen Bundestag eine Gedenkstunde
für die Opfer des Nationalsozialismus
gehabt in einzigartigerweise tragen wir
Deutsche Verantwortung für unsere
Geschichte und dafür jüdisches Leben
hier und überall sicher zu machen der
barbarische Angriff der Hamas auf Israel
unterstreicht diesen Auftrag und ja auch
manche Reaktion auf deutschen Straßen
meine Damen und Herren ich will deshalb
in aller Deutlichkeit sagen mich bei der
Kollegin Brit Hasselmann und den
Kollegen Friedrich merärz bedanken auch
für die Worte am Anfang ihrer reden ich
möchte eine Wahrheit heute aussprechen
dass die
AFD hier heute in einem demokratischen
Parlament sitzt und von Migration
spricht ist geschichtsvergessen und
gruselig meine Damen und
Herren
die die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat eine
lange Migrationsgeschichte und verdankt
auch seinen Wiederaufbau und das
ehemalige das damalige Wirtschaftswunder
verlangt es Menschen die zu uns gekommen
sind wir sind ein weltoffenes Land Herr
märz ist es richtig ich teile die
Ausführung das Thema migr
Bedarf Recht und Ordnung keine Frage
aber gleichzeitig das Signal heute aus
dem Bundestag geht nach Deutschland aus
die demokratischen Parteien der
politischen Mitte sie stehen zur
Weltoffenheit für Menschen die zu uns
kommen und uns sich bei uns integrieren
wollen die ranklatzen wollen die unser
Land mit uns gemeinsam nach vorne
bringen wollen sie sind in Deutschland
herzlich willkommen liebe Kollegin
Kollegen
und richtig ist auch dass die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte zweimal im
Jahr jetzt haben wir sie im letzten Jahr
gehabt im September jetzt im Januar
etwas verspätet ich komme darauf gleich
noch einmal zu sprechen es ist ein guter
Anlass über Grundsätze der Politik zu
sprechen und Herr Kollege März weil sie
das vorhin angesprochen haben es ist
gute parlamentarische Tradition dass wir
eben zweimal im Jahr die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte im Rahmen
der Beratungen zum Bundeshaushalt
durchführen deshalb ist es es ist
deshalb gut weil sich am konkreten
Handeln von Regierung und Opposition
ablesen lässt ob man willens und in der
Lage ist das rhetorisch vorgetragene
auch in konkrete Politik umzusetzen und
da lieber Kollege März liebe Kollegin
Kollegen der CDU CSU weil sie selbst
angesprochen haben da ist die Antwort im
Bezug auf ihre Fraktion leider null sie
kritisieren hier am Pult rauf und runter
aber sind nicht in der Lage einen
einzigen Änderungsvorschlag zum
Bundeshaushalt 2024 zu machen das
spricht Bänd ein Fehler ein
fundamentaler strategischer Fehler den
sie heute begangen haben aus meiner
Sicht ein fundamentaler
Fehler wenn Sie Herr MZ wenn Sie selbst
schon keine Idee haben hätten sie doch
wenigstens die zahlreichen über 500
Änderungsanträge der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion aus der letzten
Wahlperiode stellen können viele haben
es übrigens rhetorisch hier gerade
eingeführt und ich will sagen
zugegebenermaßen da ist nicht mehr so
viel übrig von den damaligen
Änderungsanträgen weil die meisten
Vorschläge die wir damals vorgetragen
hab heute in regierungshandel umgesetzt
werden im Deutschen Bundestag meine
Damen und Herren wir machen das
real aber Herr März der Grund warum ich
das anspreche und sage die
allgemeinpolitische Debatte findet im
Rahmen der Haushaltsberatung statt der
Grund warum ich das anspreche was sagt
es
über ihre Partei aus die sich
richtigerweise anschickt auch in ferner
Zukunft einmal wieder
Regierungsverantwortung in Deutschland
zu übernehmen wenn sie nicht einmal zu
Oppositionszeiten in der Lage ist
konkrete Vorschläge zu machen reden ist
gut handeln ist besser selbst wenn
Anträge abgelehnt werden ich ermutige
sie machen sie
Oppositionsarbeit das ist ihr Job das
ist ihr
Job und ich habe das vorhin angedeutet
wir führen jetzt die abschließende
Beratung des Bundeshaushaltes im Januar
2024 statt wegen eines Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 15
November es war wegweisend aus meiner
Sicht das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
die Schuldenbremse im Kern gestärkt und
Änderung an langjähriger statspraxis von
uns verlangt weesweisend war aber auch
die Art und Weise wie diese Koalition
mit den Folgen umgegangen ist wir können
heute feststellen dass wir das Urteil
des Verfassungsgerichts eins zu eins im
Bundeshaushalt umsetz
zugleich wird dieser Bundeshaushalt der
erste sein seit 2019 der die
Schuldenbremse wieder voll umfänglich
einhält das ist ein Erfolg nicht nur
dieser Regierung sondern aller
Steuerzahler Steuerzahler in Deutschland
Liebe Kolleginen Kollegen aber wir
können wir können da sehr gern in die
direkten Vergleich gehen wir haben denn
unionsgeführte Bundesländer auf das
haushaltsurteil reagiert gab es da harte
Verhandlung zur ne isierung von
Staatsausgaben Beispiel Berlin der
Regierende Bürgermeister Kai Wegner hält
die Schuldenbremse für Zitat gefährlich
der Berliner Rechnungshof hat die Pläne
für ein neues Klima Sondervermögen als
unvereinbar mit dem karlshoher Urteil
gebranntenmkt schlesßig holzstein die
Koalition von Herrn Günther hat Ende
November eine außergewöhnliche
Notsituation für 2023 und 24
festgestellt und nimmt weiter
munterkredite auf als ob es das Urteil
nicht gegeben haben ich weiß es wird
richtigerweise auch über die
Schuldenbremse in diesem Haus
demokratisch gestritten aber ich will
mit einem Vorurteil aufhören es wird
behauptet die Schuldenbremse sei eine
Investitionsbremse doch der Haushalt
2024 er ist der Beweis dafür dass das
nicht der Fall ist denn trotz gehärteter
oder gerade wegen gehärteter
Schuldenbremse bringen wir umfassende
Zukunftsinvestitionen auf den Weg diese
Koalition schafft es dass der
Bundeshaushalt
2024 eine fast
50% höhere Investitionsquote hat als das
2019 in Ihrer Verantwortung noch der
Fall war im Verkehrsbereich im
Verkehrsbereich wir
investieren in schiine in Straße in
Wasserstraße im Vergleich zum letzten
Jahr 40% mehr und liebe Kollegin
Kollegen der Union das ist einerseits
eine Leistung dieser Koalition
andererseits aber auch die notwendige
Antwort auf sagen wir es offen eine
katastrophale Infrastruktur
Infrastrukturpolitik der
Verkehrsminister Alexander dobrint und
andreas Scheuer liebe Kollegin Kollegen
katastrophal was sie gemacht haben das
räumen wir jetzt auf das korrigieren
wir war mE ein Fehler sich jahrelang
nicht um die deutschen Brücken gekümmert
zu haben sondern lieber sich mit einer
ausländermaut beschäftigt zu haben
zweitens
mit mit 12 Milliarden EUR 12 Milliarden
Euro legen wir die Grundlage für die
aktienrente für das
generationkapital das ist einerseits
einer Leistung dieser Koalition
andererseits aber auch bitter notwendig
angesichts eines immer weiter steigenden
Bundeszuschuss in die gesetzliche
Rentenversicherung wir brauchen mehr
Kapitaldeckung Herr März es war ein
Fehler dass sie in den lang CDU
geführten Bundesregierung in den langen
Jahren mit den überfälligen Einstieg in
die Kapitaldeckung unserer Rente nicht
angefangen haben das korrigieren wir
jetzt mit diesem Bundeshaushalt meine
Damen und Herren
und wir sorgen damit dass die
Steuerquote in Deutschland sinkt zum 1
Januar 2024 der Bundeskanzler hat es
vorhin angesprochen haben wir die
arbeitende Mitte erneut bei der lohnum
Einkommenssteuer um 15 Milliarden Euro
entlastet das ist einerseits eine
Leistung dieser Koalition andererseits
aber auch bitter notwendig angesetetzt
langjährigers steuerpolitischen
Stillstands in Deutschland und immer
weiter zunehmender Belastung der
Arbeiten Mitte in ihrer
Regierungsverantwortung um das in aller
Klarheit zu sagen ein Fehler den diese
Koalition jetzt korrigiert für die
arbeitende Mitte in unserem
Land und ich will das an dem Beispiel
deutlich sagen weil ich sie riefen
vorhin bei der Rede des Bundeskanzlers
dazwischen er würde reden wie ein
Generalsekretär ich habe den berei
gesessen ich find Generalsekretäre sind
ganz wunderbare Redner um das noch mal
zu unterstreichen aber ich will auf
etwas anderes hinaus ich habe nämlich
gelesen was ihr
Generalsekretär im Bezug auf steuerliche
Reform in Deutschland gesagt hat er hat
gesagt man müsse bei der
einkommenenssteuer eine
Rechtsverschiebung des Tarifes machen um
die arbeitende Mitte zu entlasten genau
das tut diese Koalition ich habe mir die
Frage gestellt wenn sie solche Dinge im
Kopf haben warum bringen sie sowas nicht
in den Bundestag ein für sie sind
Steuersenkung immer nur Wahlkampf nie
Regierung und parlamentshandel das
unterscheidet uns von Ihnen liebe
Kolleginen
Kollegen und ich will einen weiteren
Punkt ansprechen das
stchancenprogramm was wir auch mit
diesem Bundeshaushalt absichern was
unsere Bundesbildungsministerin bertina
stark Watzinger auf den Weg bringt im
kommenden Jahr in den kommenden 10
Jahren 4000 Schwerpunktschulen mit
insgesamt 20 Milliarden Euro zu
unterstützen wir helfen damit eine
Million Kinder in unserem Land das ist
einerseits eine Leistung dieser
Koalition andererseits angesichts der
schlechten pisaergebnisse in unserem
Land aber auch bitter notwendig Herr
märz ist war ein Fehler dass das
Bildungsministerium in Deutschland
jahrelang von Durchsetzung schwachen
Bundesministerin ihrer Partei besetzt
worden ist das hat sich jetzt geändert
liebe Kollegin Kollegen und ich sag das
deshalb weil wir viel über
Zukunftschancen reden und ich bin
dankbar dass sich die Länder am Ende des
Tages bewegt haben hoffentlich bewegen
werden und genau dieses
staatschancenprogramm zur Unterschrift
kommt aber es geht ja um mehr wer Recht
hat oder wer nicht hat in der
Bildungspolitik es geht um wesentlich
mehr es geht um die Chancen junger
Menschen es ist die
himmelschreidenste soziale
Ungerechtigkeit in Deutschland dass die
Chancen junger Menschen vom Elternhaus
abhängen das muss sich ändern jeder
junge Mensch hat eine Chance da geht's
nicht um soziale Unterstützung sondern
um faere Bildungschancen und das setzen
wir in dieser Koalition an liebe
Kollegin
Kollegen und Herr März sie haben
richtigerweise auch über die
wirtschaftliche Situation in unserem
Lande gesprochen die herausfordern ist
das teile ich ausdrücklich ich will
hinzufügen manchen Vorwurf lasse ich mir
allerdings nicht machen dass wir hinter
dem Scherbenhaufen den sie angerichtet
haben nicht schnell genug
hinterherkehren aber wir tun etwas
beispielsweise die Stromsteuer für das
produzierende Gewerbe um
96% gesenkt das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz für Startups
der Bundeskanzler sprach davon wir haben
hier national das getan was notwendig
ist um unseren Gründungsstandort zu
stärken und schließlich mit dem Wachstum
chancengesetz entlasten wir die
Unternehmen in Deutschland und setzen
ein sehr wichtiges Signal für
Investitionsanreize und
Forschungsvorhaben in neue Technologie
und da verstehe ich nicht ihre Strategie
ich will das in aller Deutlichkeit sagen
bei genau dieser Zukunftsfrage der
Bundesfinanzminister hat in seiner Rede
bei der finanzpolitischen Debatte
gestern gesagt dass ihm der vorm redende
Kollege Matthias Middelberg aus meinem
geschätzten Heimatland Niedersachsen
vorkomme wie ein
Marsianer der vor 14 Tagen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag gelandet ist sich
umschaut was aus Deutschland geworden
ist wo die Probleme liegen das zu nicht
in Infrastruktur investiert worden ist
in der Vergangenheit und die
wirtschaftlichen Herausforderungen da
sind ich muss eines feststellen nach den
Debatten zu Einzelplänen am gestrigen
Tag und ihrer Rede am heutigen Vormittag
Herr Kollege März Herr
Bundesfinanzminister wir haben es nicht
mit einem einzelnen Marsianer zu tun es
ist eine Invasion von marsian die wir
hier erleben die sich offensichtlich an
nichts aber auch gar nichts erinnern
können und jetzt nicht einmal in der
Lage sind das
wachstumschancengesetz durch dennd
Bundesrat zu bringen das wäre ihre
Aufgabe als CDU und CSU in diesen harten
Situation auch für die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen und deswegen und deswegen will
ich eines zum Schluss sagen weil am
Anfang auch in verschiedenen Regeln über
Migrationspolitik gesprochen worden ist
ja ich habe gesagt mehr Recht und
Ordnung in der Durchsetzung und
gleichzeitig das ganze mit Weltoffenheit
verbinden deswegen haben wir das
Fachkräfte einwanderungs Gesetz hier im
Bundestag beschlossen und das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht novelliert
aber eines finde ich besonders spannend
als ich als Fraktionsvorsitzender der
FDP im letzten Oktober gesagt habe dass
ich vor den Ministerpräsidenten in der
MPK am 6 November eine klare Zusage zur
Bezahlkarte erwarte da war das Wort
Bezahlkarte im Wortschatz der Union noch
gar nicht verankert dass Sie sich jetzt
hier hinstellen und die Bezahlkarte
hochleben lassen ist ein Treppenwitz der
Geschichte ich bin und der Kanzler hat
gesagt dankbar dass endlich der klaren
Positionierung meiner Partei und dieser
Koalition beim Thema Bezahlkarte Folge
geleistet wird Boris rin hat erklärt sie
kommt in allen 16 Ländern das ist ein
gutes Signal zeigt übrigens dass
Deutschland insgesamt handlungsfähig ist
also bitte mehr Zeitung lesen dann sind
sie auch up to date bei ihren
Haushaltsreden Herr März ich danke
ihnen minut
[Musik]
und für die Unionsfraktion hat jetzt das
Wort Alexander
doprint frau Präsidentin sehr Gerte
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben heute morgen in der
Tat zwei sehr ergreifende Schilderungen
von Eva
und Marcel re gehört die uns noch mal
sehr deutlich gemacht haben was die
demokratische Mitte dieses Hauses ein
dass sich eben nicht wiederholt was sich
nicht wiederholen darf und dass wir
diese Demokratie gegen diejenigen
verteidigen müssen die sie angreifen und
da ist es in der Tat ein großartiges
Zeichen wenn in den vergangenen Tagen
und Wochen tausende Menschen in
Deutschland gegen den Rechtsextremismus
auf die Straße gegangen sind ein großes
Zeichen unserer lebendigen Demokratie
und sehr der Bundeskanzler sie haben
hier im Rednerpult vorhin gesagt wir
müssen als Demokraten zusammenstehen ja
wir müssen als Demokraten zusammenstehen
aber zu einer Demokratie gehört eben
auch eine Opposition in der Mitte dieses
Parlaments und der sollte man mit mehr
Respekt begegnen als sie das in ihrer
Erklärung hier gemacht
haben der Sinn von politik besteht nicht
ausschließlich im Ausdruck einer Haltung
sondern in der Bewältigung von Problemen
zu jasperar von alten Bockum vor kurzen
in seiner Zeitung ich stimme ihm
ausdrücklich zu es geht um die
Bewältigung von Problemen und sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler dass sie ihn
anbitt trcht der Lage in der die Ampel
dieses Land gebracht hat heute kein
Stück Einsicht und Demut gezeigt haben
das ist wirklich der Gipfel der
raugansz haben Sie sich eigentlich die
Konjunkturdaten von gestern mal im
Detail angeschaut haben sie sich
angeschaut was alle Institute über
Deutschland im Vergleich zu Europa und
der Welt zum Auszug bringen es ist ein
ein weiteres Schrumpfen des vergangenen
Jahres von
-0,3% festgestellt worden es gibt eine
pessimistische PR Prognose mit negativem
Wachstum für das Jahr
2024 und dann ist noch der
internationale währungsvor dazu gekommen
dass er Deutschland drastisch nach unten
abstuft während für die ganze Welt für
Europa für alle Industrienationen die
Prognosen nach oben gehen wird
Deutschland als einzige Industrie Nation
abgewertet die Kernaussage ist eindeutig
und klar Deutschland steckt in der
Rezession die Krise verfestet sich das
Land wird weiter abgehängt und die
Verantwortung liegt dafür bei der
ampelregierung und nirgendwo anders
meine Damen und
Herren her Bundeskanzler sie haben in
der letzten Woche in der Zeitung die
Zeit wörtliches Zitat die Koalition
mutet sich angesichts der großen
Herausforderungen Konflikte zu die
Koalition mutet sich Konflikte zu nein
Herr Bundeskanzler es ist umgekehrt
nicht die Ampel mutet sich etwas zu
sondern die Ampel ist eine Zumutung für
die Menschen in Deutschland das ist die
Wahrheit eine Zumutung für die Bauern
eine Zumutung für die Spediteure eine
Zumutung für die Gastronomen eine
Zumutung fürs Handwerk eine Zumutung für
den ländlichen Raum sie bieten in ihrem
Haushalt dazu auch überhaupt keine
Lösungen an hören Sie doch aufständig
dazwischenrufen sie sind einfach
schlichtweg nicht das Opfer dieser
Konflikte sie sind der Urheber dieser
Konflikte die ich da gerade
beseschrieben
habe sie bieten keine Lösungen an
glauben Sie dass Sie mit 20 Milliarden
zusätzlichen Steuererhöhungen mit 40
Milliarden neuen Schulden irgendwas zur
Befriedung in diesem Land beitragen sie
haben sich vom Sparen komplett
verabschiedet sie haben sich schlichtweg
verabschiedet meine Damen und
Herren mit Bürgergeld mit halsgesetz mit
Steuererhöhungen haben sie die
Polarisierung in diesem Land weiter
vorangetrieben und jetzt und jetzt
spricht der Finanzminister gestern hier
an diesem Rednerpult davon dass er nicht
mehr über einen Sparhaushalt nachdenkt
sondern über einen
gestaltungshaushalt meine Damen und
Herren sie sind keine Koalition der
Gestaltung sie sind eine Koalition der
Spaltung das sehen Sie auf den Straßen
jeden Tag in diesem
Land und in diesem in dieser Situation
in der sie Deutschland gebracht haben
spricht der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister davon dass
Unternehmen mehr
standortpatriotismus zeigen sollten das
ist in der Tat ein beeindruckender
Versuch Ursache und Wirkung umzukehren
die Unternehmer sind nicht schlultld an
der schlechten Wirtschaftssituation sie
sind das Opfer ihrer schlechten
Wirtschaftspolitik so ist
es diejenigen von denen man mehr
standortpatriotismus erwarten müsste die
sitzen am
Kabinettstisch Standort Patriotismus
würde heißen nicht die deutschen
Kernkraftwerke abschalten und dann
französische Kernenergie kaufen
standortpatriotismus würde bedeuten die
landwirtschaftliche Produktion im Land
zu erhalten anstatt sie abzuwirken
standortpatriotismus würde heißen den
Mittelstand zu entlasten anstatt die
Steuern zu erhöhen und
standortpatriotismus würde bedeuten die
Erbschaftssteuer zu regalisieren anstatt
sie zu erhöhen und die Leute damit
zusätzlich zu belassen das wäre
standardpatriotismus in diesem
Land die Arbeitgeber sprechen davon dass
die Unternehmen das Vertrauen in die
Regierung verloren haben die Metal
spricht davon dass es eine schleichende
Deindustrialisierung in diesem gibt und
sie Herr Bundeskanzler sprechen davon
dass sie alles dafür getan haben dass
sich Arbeit lohnt meine Damen und Herren
das ist der glatte Hohn gegenüber
denjenigen die heute das Gefühl haben
dass sich Arbeit in diesem Land nicht
mehr rentiert ihre Politik überfordert
schlichtweg dieses
[Applaus]
Land die
Gesellschaft das war ein Artikel der von
Allensbach veröffentlicht worden ist
immer mehr Menschen glauben dass sich
schlichtweg Arbeit nicht mehr lohnt und
dass sich gerade Menschen mit mittlerem
und den kleinen Einkommen so äußern
dafür gibt es doch auch einen Grund
dreiviertel der Menschen sind der
Überzeugung dass das Bürgergeld davon
abhalte in Beschäftigung zu kommen ertel
glauben dass das Bürgergeld
Beschäftigung verhindert ihr Bürgergeld
hat schlichtweg an Akzeptanz verloren
und ihr Bürgergeld sorgt dafür dass auch
Arbeit an Akzeptanz verliert weil die
Arbeitnehmer nicht mehr respektiert
werden von
ihnen schauen Sie sich doch mal an was
mit diesem Bürgergeld entstanden ist
gibt neue Rechnungen es gibt neue
Rechnungen die sagen würde sich eine
Familie die heute 2000 € 3000 € verdient
auf den Weg machen und mit weiteren 2000
€ verdienen wollen dann kämen sie gerade
auf 32 € mehr Netto so sieht doch kein
funktionierender Sozialstaat aus der die
Schwachen schützt nein so sieht ein
Sozialstaat aus der die
leistungsbereiten bestraft und das ist
die Realität mit ihrem Bürgergeld
[Applaus]
und Herren es gibt eine ganze Menge zu
kritisieren an dem was diese Ampel mit
ihrem Haushaltsentwurf an Fehlern macht
aber sehr geehrte Frau Weidel lassen
sich an dieser Stelle sagen ihre
Einlassung diese Regierung hasst
Deutschland die ist mit aller Schär
zurüuisen diese Regierung regiert
schlecht aber sie HST dieses Land
nicht und ich sage Ihnen
das ja es wird nicht besser wenn sie es
wiederholen an dieser Stelle wissen Sie
ich gebe Ihnen hier auch was mit auf den
Weg
SPD Grüne
FDP und CDU und CSU wir hassen auch
dieses Europa
wir hassen dieses Europa
nicht weil auch diese Europäische Union
der Garant für Demokratie für Freiheit
und für Wohlstand zwischen unseren
Partnerländern ist und ich weiß ja nicht
ob es überhaupt noch jemand bei Ihnen
realisiert was in ihrer Partei passiert
wo haben Sie sich denn eigentlich
hingewegt von zu höcke da stehen sie
jetzt wo soll es denn eigentlich
weitergehen mit ihrer Partei ich kann
Ihnen sagen wenn einer aus ihrer
Fraktion aus ihrer Partei sagt diese EU
muss sterben dann ist er unser
schärfster Gegner wenn sie sagen das
brexit ist der Modell für Deutschland
dann sind Sie unser schärfster Gegner
sie arbeiten am Ruin dieses Landes um
das mal sehr deutlich so zu sagen und
ich kann ihn auch nur
ans Herz
legen sprechen Sie einfach weiter
darüber dass sie aus der Europäischen
Union aussteigen wollen dass sie den
Euro aufgeben wollen dass sie aus der
NATO aussteigen wollen und reden Sie
bitte auch weiter darüber dass sie sich
Putins eurasischer Wirtschaftsunion
annähern wollen reden sie darüber dass
sie das freie Europa zerstören und sich
dem russischen Diktator anschließen
wollen sie sind nicht die Alternative
für Deutschland die Alternative die sie
anbütigen anbieten das ist die
Alternative der Unmündigkeit der unter
Unterwerfung der Unfreiheit das hat mit
Patriotismus nichts zu tun das ist
vaterlandsverat was von ihnen hier
kommt
weiter ja
ist schwer zu ertragen die Wahrheit ist
an dieser Stelle sehr schwer zu ertragen
ich verstehe das sehr gete Damen und
Herren will ih nur Herr D für ihre Rede
den kleinen Hinweis
geben sie haben davon gesprochen sie
seien auf dem richtigen Weg ihre
Umfragewerte haben sich von über 11% auf
3% entwickelt 8% Verlust wenn das der
richtige Weg ist dann ist das das ein
Beispiel von autosubtition wie wir es
hier selten erlebt haben meine Damen und
Herren und sehr geehrte Frau Hasselmann
ich will ihnen das auch mit auf den Weg
geben sie haben hier formuliert in
Richtung von CDU und CSU reden sie das
Land nicht schlecht ich sage Ihnen
regieren sie dieses Land nicht schlecht
Rechtsextremismus kann man auch nur dann
bekämpfen wenn man ihn nicht einfach nur
demstriert oder verbieten will sondern
man muss ihn auch wegreieren und da
haben sie zurzeit noch Verantwortung
meine Damen und
Herren und der nächste Redner ist für
die aktion dr Rolf
müz ser gete frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich denke es ist gut wenn man
ein bisschen versucht diese Debatte auch
in einem Ton zu
führen und ich muss auch für die größte
Fraktion in Koalition sagen ja in
spannungsreichen und aufwühlenden Zeiten
ist es fast unmöglich immer und überall
Zuversicht und Sicherheit zu stiften
Kriege der Wandel der internationalen
Ordnung wirtschaftliche Unsicherheiten
und politisches abenteuertum liegen
außerhalb unseres
Einflusses und ich muss es bekennen dass
wir aber durch unser Verhalten in der
Koalition manchmal Verdruss und
Besorgnis befördert haben ist fahrlässig
und das betrübt mich auch und wir haben
zugelassen dass unsere Differenzen
leider auch der Demokratie als solcher
zugeordnet wurden das muss aufhören wir
müssen anders arbeiten und unseren
Ansprüchen besser gerecht werden
politische Grundsatzdebatten darf man
auch in dieser Koalition führen
Eigennutz Unhöflichkeit und
Besserwisserei untereinander meine Damen
und Herren müssen dagen
auför liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
ich sag das ich sag das ja ich glaube
sie können das eben nicht sich auch mal
auf sich selbst zu beziehen das ist
glaube ich der Unterschied deswegen sage
ich ja in dieser Koalition und das
wussten wir von Anfang an wir sind
unterschiedliche Parteien aber das
brauchen wir nicht jeden Tag zu betonen
wichtiger ist dass diese drei Parteien
zusamm gefunden haben weil sie wissen
dass Gesetze auch Kompromisse sind aber
am Ende legen wir die Planken wir
schaffen das
Fundament für glasklare Veränderungen in
diesem Land weil das eben in der
Vergangenheit nicht gelungen ist
deswegen sage
ich die Vollkommenheit einer Bestimmung
ist nicht das Entscheidende sondern das
Entscheidende ist dass dieses Fundament
nicht wieder zurückgedreht werden kann
auch nicht von denen die die die 90er
Jahre des letzten Jahrhunderts zurück
wollen das ist die Leistung und das ist
der Erfolg meine Damen und Herren dieser
Regierung und wir brauchen wir brauchen
mehr von dieser möglichkeitspolitik und
wenn man das bedenkt und beachtet kann
man auch stolz auf das Geschaffene sein
und es wird schwerlich möglich
vielleicht irgendwann für andere
politische Mehrheiten etwas
zurückzudrehen was diese Koalition
geschaffen hat
und ich will mal sagen das Recht auf
Ausbildung das ist ein fundamentaler
Erfolg für die jungen Menschen in diesem
Land wenn sie keinen Ausbildungsplatz
finden außerbetriebliche Bildung
letztlich auch hier zu bekommen
Qualifizierungen und Mindestlohn ein
besseres Eltern und Kindergeld Wohngeld
Gesundheit und Renten für die Menschen
die erwerbsgemindert sind das sind die
fundamentalen Entscheidungen die in
dieser getroffen worden sind und genau
das ist das Fundament für ein soziales
Deutschland wo auch wir Sozialdemokraten
und Sozialdemokraten stolz drauf sind
meine Damen und Herren umso mehr und das
frage ich mich Herr Kollege Merz wissen
Sie eigentlich wenn sie über das
Bürgergeld so reden mal unabhängig davon
dass sie und das haben wir ja jetzt
schon öfter auch festgestellt zugestimmt
haben und dem Mindestlohn leider nicht
wissen sie dass das
Bürgergeld von jedem fünften der in
Beschäftigung ist genutzt werden muss
weil das Gehalt das Einkommen zu gering
ist das sind Aufstocker wieso reden sie
über diese Menschen so dass ihnen das
Bürgergeld nicht zusteht das passt nicht
zu einem christlichen
Menschenbild und kranke Menschen die
eine Behinderung haben ein Handicap auch
die bekommen Bürgergeld weil sie nicht
in dieser Situation arbeiten können so
kann man nicht mit diesen Menschen
umgehen die auf ein Fundament angewiesen
sind nämlich einem sozialen Netz was
dieses Deutschland nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg schaffen wollte meine Damen
und
Herren und
deswegen wir haben Wort gehalten nicht
nur für diese fundamentalen Reform die
wir in den letzten zwei Jahren auf den
Weg gebracht haben sondern eben in
diesen spannungsreichen und auffühlenden
Zeit genau das zu tun um Wort zu halten
was wir den Menschen auch versprochen
haben nämlich strukturbrüche zu
vermeiden durch starke
Haushaltspolitik dass wir es geschafft
haben existentielle sorgen den Menschen
auch in einer Situation zu geben am Ende
der Pandemie wo Russland die Ukraine
überfallen hat wo die Kriegsangst wächst
aber eben auch die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen Herausforderung da
haben wir Halt gegeben und darauf können
wir doch auch stolz sein meine Damen und
Herren und ich finde gerade in diesen
Tagen wo wieder über Tarifpolitik
gesprochen wird Herr Bundeskanzler hat
die konzertierte Aktion eingeladen das
war gut mit den Gewerkschaften mit den
Arbeitgebern zu versuchen diese
strukturbrüche in unserem Land zu
vermeiden um gute Arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten und Investitionen
voranzubringen aber in dieser
konzertierten Aktion ist auch der
Grundstein für eine gute Tarifpolitik
gelegt worden weil nämlich und da hat
sich jede Gewerkschaft am Ende drauf
bezogen 3000
3000 € Steuer und abgabenfi gewesen ist
das ist ein wichtiges Zeichen gewesen
und das zeigt dass dieser Staat dass
diese Regierung Verantwortung trägt und
das darf man nicht schlecht reden in
diesen Zeiten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und ich sag das auch für eine
Fraktion die selbstbewusst ist manches
was die Regierung in ihrem
Haushaltsentwurf auf den Weg gebracht
hat war auch für die
Mitglieder dieser Koalition für die
sozialdemokratische Fraktion
herausfordern das war nicht leicht weil
das ein oder andere was doch in dem
Haushaltsentwurf stand das hat durchaus
zu sorgen das hat zu Verunsicherung in
den Wahlkreisen geführt und ich fand
manches was uns daf die Tür gekippt
wurde war schwer auch zu wieder zu
reparieren aber wir haben es geschafft
und das ist genau das was dieses
Parlament leistet was diese Koalition
leistet am Ende schaffen wir wieder
Vertrauen und es ist gelungen z.B im
Bereich des Sports im Bereich der
politischen Bildung bei der frei bei den
Freiwilligendiensten bei der
Migrationsberatung alles das haben wir
wieder korrigiert und auch die
Integration für den Arbeitsmarkt die
Qualifizierung das sind wichtige
Elemente gewesen die in diesem Haushalt
sich wiederfinden meine Damen und Herren
und es ist gut dass die Mitglieder
dieser Koalition auch deutliche
Korrekturen an diesem Haushalt
vorgenommen haben deswegen können wir
auch guten Gewissens heute diese am
Freitag diesem Haushalt zusehmen meine
Damen und Herren und was der Unterschied
letztlich macht wir wenden uns den
Menschen zu ohne diese Abgeordneten wäre
es nicht möglich gewesen dass wir
endlich das untersuchen worunter Kinder
und Jugendliche zu einem kleinen Teil
leiden aber was sie nach einer
coviderkrankung erleiden müssen jetzt
muss geklärt werden was können wir
diesen Kindern und Jugendlichen anbieten
das ist sozusagen ein Dienst am Menschen
am jungen Menschen genau diese Richtung
hat diese Koalition eingeschlagen und
der
Haushaltsgesetzgeber meine Damen und
Herren hat es korrigiert und vielleicht
mal
erinnernd an die
heutige se
beeindruckende Holocaust Gedenkstunde
wir haben für jüdisches Leben noch mal
mehr Mittel bereitgestellt damit endlich
das aufhört was in dieses Land hätte nie
einziehen dürfen ein Antisemitismus der
sich gegen unsere jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger richtet und
manchmal von den geistigen Brandstiftern
seit Jahren auch schon provoziert worden
ist meine Damen und Herren darauf bin
ich
und wir haben wir haben diese Dinge
angepackt und deswegen können wir uns
auch besser erwähren den
Herausforderungen die diese Demokratie
die so schwer errichtet wurde sich in
diesen Tagen auch stellen muss und die
Voraussetzungen meine Damen und Herren
sind besser denn je Frau Hasselmann hat
hier vorgelesen in welchen Gemeinden in
welchen großen Städten aber auch in den
nächsten Tagen Menschen sich nicht mehr
mit diesem geistigen Gehalt abfinden
wollen in diesem Land das ist wichtig
aber es darf nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und das sage ich auch bei
diesen Demonstrationen bleiben deswegen
sage ich zu allen die auf die Straße
gehen oder alle die sagen ich möchte
wiedersprechen gehen sie zu ihren
Nachbarn zu den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zu ihren Freunden und sagen den was es
bedeutet AFD zu wählen es geht nicht
darum zu sagen den die Wählerinnen und
Wähler anzuklagen sondern es geht darum
wie fahrlässig man sein würde wenn man
das
tut behinderte junge Menschen werden als
Belastung in diesem Land von hern höcke
beschrieben und das werden nicht die
Ersten sein die eben auch in diese
Situation kommen sie wollen den
Mindestlohn abschaffen aber gleich
zeitig wollen sie die reichsten in
diesem Land entlasten sie sind gegen
alle Subventionen auch gegen die
Subvention für die Landwirte in diesem
Land sie wollen keine Subvention für
gute und neue Arbeitsplätze sie
ruinieren das Land und ich bin froh wenn
diejenigen die gegen sie demonstrieren
dass auch ihren Freunden ihren Nachbarn
und ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen sagen
wir sind auf sie angewiesen seinen sie
eine Stimme gegen die Partei die dieses
Land eren würde meine Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren und ich will zum
Schluss auf jeden Fall das ist wichtig
auch noch mal auf zwei grundsätzliche
Fragen eingehen die in den letzten
Wochen auch die öffentliche Diskussion
beschäftigt haben ich will etwas zum
Kindergeld und zum Kinderfreibetrag
sagen wenn ich das mal so offen von
diesem reterpuls auch erwähnen darf ich
empfinde es als etwas als ein
trippenwitz der Geschichte
dass wir vor z Jahren es geschafft haben
für jedes Kind für jedes Kind 250 €
Kindergeld deutlich
anzuheben und erst jetzt fällt das in
der Diskussion auf dass einige meinen
jetzt geht es wieder um den
Kinderfreibetrag ich finde das schade
ich hätte mir letztlich anderes
gewünscht aber das ist auch an meine
Adresse an meine Adresse gerichtet aber
was ich sehr deutlich sagen will wir
haben es nicht nur getan weil jedes Kind
die gleiche Leistung erhalten muss
sondern wir haben es auch gemacht weil
im Koalitionsvertrag steht die Differenz
zwischen Kindergeld und Kinderfreibetrag
muss eingegrenzt werden und genau
deswegen haben wir das vor z Jahren in
dieser Koalition gemacht und ja ich gebe
zu manche haben es nicht verstanden auch
als Vorleistung auf die
Kindergrundsicherung auch das war ein
wichtiges Element damals für die
Erhöhung des Kindergeldes aber ich werde
mich von diesem ich werde mich von
diesem Rednerpult gegen eins erwähen was
manche versuchen heute ich finde es
manchmal etwas perfide in die Diskussion
hineinzubringen als ob es eine
Verabredung gegeben hätte dass nach der
deutlichen Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
jetzt der Kinderfreibetrag dran ist ich
habe diese Verabredung nicht getroffen
und wiren haben das unter den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden damals besprochen
und sie wissen genau Herr gesarei was
sie damals ja weil sie haben ja diese
Behauptung in die Welt gesetzt was Sie
für diesen Kinderfreibetrag auch
letztlich bekommen haben nämlich den
informations den Inflationsausgleich für
die besser verdienen auch das gehört
meine Damen und Herren zur Wahrheit mit
dazu und ich finde eine ordentliche
Debatte muss dann auch heißen wenn der
kinderfi angepasst werden muss sage ich
für meine Fraktion dann muss auch das
Kindergeld erhöht werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und Herr D hat
eine zweite Sache angesprochen und die
gehört in der Tat zur politischen
Grundsatzdebatte in diesem Land mit dazu
wie kann ein Land was angewiesen ist auf
einen modernen auf einen aktiven auf
einen starken Staat wie kann dieser
Staat in den Umbrüchen am besten
reagieren und da hat meine Partei die
Sozialdemokratische Partei eine ganz
Glas klare Antwort gegeben auf der einen
Seite muss die Frage der
ungleichen Vermögen der großen Vermögen
in diesem Land thematisiert werden ich
finde das ist da ist nichts falsches
dran es geht letztlich darum die
Solidarität auch der starken Schultern
in diesem Land immer wieder anzusprechen
und zum anderen geht es darum wie
konkurrieren wir mit den Ländern auf der
Welt die alles dafür tun von uns
Industriearbeitsplätze abzuwerben mit
großen Investitionen mit letztlich
großen
Investitionsentscheidungen und da finde
ich muss die Antwort sein das kann
Deutschland genauso gut das muss in
Deutschland auch in nächster Zukunft
noch stärker sein weil sonst werden uns
die Industriearbeitsplätze abhen kommen
und die Leittragenden sind die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer deswegen auch für dieses
Haushaltsjahr was wir am Ende der Woche
beschließen werden ich warne vor einem
Dilemma der Bundeskanzler hat zurecht
die große Unterstützung die Deutschland
von Anfang an der Ukraine geleistet hat
hervorgehoben und appelliert an die
europäischen Länder Gleiches zu tun aber
es gibt auch noch etwas zweites an das
man appellieren muss wir dürfen nicht
die notwendige Unterstützung der Ukraine
ausspielen gegen andere notwendige
Investitionen in diesem Land beides
gehört zusammen und dafür bin ich für
einen modernen und letztlich auch
starken Staat meine Damen und Herren und
deswegen Herr März wenn Sie bereit sind
ich möchte sie als
Fraktionsvorsitzender darum bitten es
noch mal zu überlegen auch vor dem
Hintergrund ihrer Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentinnen die da gesagt
haben auch die Länder wollen in Zukunft
starke Investition machen und wollen
sich im Primat der Politik nicht
einschränken wenn Sie bereit sind mit
uns über eine Reform der Schuldenbremse
im Grundgesetz noch in dieser
Legislaturperiode zu reden sind wir
davon offen ich lade sie dazu
überlegen Sie sich Ihr nein noch mal ich
glaube dem Land meine Damen und Herren
würde es gut tun wir haben einen guten
Haushalt vorgelegt und es gibt am Ende
eine weitere gute Nachricht die
vorläufige Haushaltsführung endet mit
dieser Woche und geht zurück an die die
vom Souverän damit beauftragt wurden
dieses Mandat wer wir mit Kraft Vernunft
und Verstand zum Wohle unseres Landes
ausüben vielen
[Applaus]
Dank liebe KollegenInnen und Kollegen
Liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
zunächst einmal grüße ich Sie alle ganz
herzlich und ich gebe das Wort an Tino
kopaller für die AFD
Fraktion frs
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute liebe Gäste auf den Tribünen
ich möchte mit einem Zitat beginnen und
das schließt eigentlich auch an ihre
Rede Herr Münz nicht an weil sie uns ja
hier gerade so dargestellt haben als
wenn wir hier das Land ruinieren würden
und zwar das Zitat die Unternehmer in
Deutschland hätten das Vertrauen in die
Bundesregierung verloren Zitat Ende und
das sagte näich der Arbeitgeber
Präsident reiner Dulger der FAZ und muss
sagen auch bei Ihnen auf der
Regierungsbank sollten mittlerweile die
Alarmsignale doch längst angekommen sein
wo bleibt eigentlich Herr Bundeskanzler
ihr Respekt von dem sie ja im Wahlkampf
so viel gesprochen haben gegenüber den
Bauern und Bürgern die über Generationen
hinweg hier diesen Wirtschaftsmotor
Deutschland am Laufen gehalten haben und
wenn man keinen Respekt hab und hat dann
liebt man dieses Land auch nicht und das
zeigen sie jeden Tag mit ihrer
Bundesregierung und es sind eben genau
die Menschen die uns alle hier gewählt
haben um eine Politik für Deutschland zu
machen sie machen Politik aber für wen
machen Sie eigentlich Politik Frau
Hasselmann für die Beratungsunternehmen
und die Millionen schweren Verträge im
Rahmen der Energiewende für ihre
Rüstungslobby für diese Menschen ist
Milliarden Euro an Geld da aber nicht
für die einfachen Bürger für diejenigen
die jeden Tag hart arbeiten und meine
Damen und Herren jeder Steuereuro muss
erstmal verdient werden erst dann können
wir hier darüber entscheiden wo er gut
investiert werden kann und ich kann nur
sagen dass ihre Schwerpunkt e nicht
nachvollziehbar sind denn die Wirtschaft
Lage wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland
sie ist desolat dazu einige Eckpunkte
Deutschland ist der einzige G7 Staat
ohne Wirtschaftswachstum Deutschland ist
im Z Halbjahr 2023 in eine reziss
gerutscht die Gründe dafür sind hohe
Energiekosten die grüne Transformation
und schlechte Standortbestimmungen die
Ernsthaftigkeit der Lage ist
offensichtlich warum reduzieren sie
selbst als Bundesregierung und auch das
if tut bereits die
wirtschaftswachstumserwartung für
2024 und ja jetzt kommen sie wieder mit
den internationalen Märkten und die
Kriege die wir leider wieder zu beklagen
haben zu diesen haben wir als
Alternative für Deutschland unsere
Position oft genug darelegt wir brauchen
Frieden und wir wie auch die Bürger
wollen keinen Kampf mehr von Systemen
und von Ideologien und genau diese
Kriege sind eben nicht verantwortlich
dafür dass sie als Bundesregierung die
die von Ihnen selbst verursachten
Standortnachteile weiter in Kauf nehmen
schauen sie endlich über den Tellerrand
hinaus auch wenn es anstrengt ist und
sicherlich für Sie auch enttäuschend ist
die Firmen wandern ab oder wollen
abwandern und wenn man als Unternehmer
ständig rote Zahlen schreibt gibt es
nicht die Möglichkeit mehr Ausgaben als
Einnahmen zu verursachen ein Unternehmer
muss sich auch an geltende Gesetze
halten und kann sie nicht einfach
umgehen das kann nur diesend Regierung
indem sie die Schuldenbremse die vor
staatsverfolgung z schützen sein soll
einfach aussetzt bei dieser
wirtschaftlichen Bilanz ist das
verantwortungslos und vor allen Dingen
staatsschädigend und wir haben es
gesehen im letzten Haushalt
verfassungswidrig was sie hier in diesem
Land
betreiben Werte Kollegen die deutsche
Wirtschaft lebt von Exporten und guten
wirtschaftlichen Beziehung in allen
Ländern darüber sind wir uns denke ich
in diesem Haus einig aber nun brechen
selbst die Exporte nach China und in die
USA ein wie kann sich eigentlich die
Arbeit für die Bürger überhaupt noch
lohnen wenn ihnen die Grundlage genommen
wird wie viele wollen sie in die
Alimentierung durch den Staat eigentlich
noch treiben für einige scheint sich
mittlerweile Erwerbsarbeit dank
Bürgergeld kaum noch zu lohnen und bei
all diesen Befunden sen sie als
ampelakteure weder Demut noch Einsicht
aus dafür treiben sie einen Spalt weiter
in die Gesellschaft und vor allen Dingen
sie drehen die Verantwortung um das ist
eigentlich der absolute Hammer den wir
aktuell hier erleben der
Bundesfinanzminister Linder sprach am
Wochenende davon das Programm der AFD
würde Deutschland wirtschaftlich
ruinieren und Herr Habig lickt nach die
AFD sei Gift für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland sehen sie eigentlich nicht
wer das wirkliche Gift in diesem Land
ist das sehen die Bürger jeden Tag indem
sie ihre Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlen
können indem immer mehr Unternehmen
pleite gehen indem immer mehr
Unternehmen abwandern und immer mehr
Bürger die Nase gestrichen voll haben
von den Bauern von von den Handwerkern
und von Mittelstand in diesem Land sehr
geehrte Damen und
Herren und Frau Hasselmann dann stellen
Sie sich hier hin und beten wieder das
große Lied der Demokratie nie wieder ist
jetzt da gebe ich ihn recht nie wieder
ist jetzt auch indem man staatskonforme
Medienhäuser quasi als zweite stasie
aufbaut und gegen die Opposition
einsetzt auch das ist nie wieder jetzt
das hatten wir alles schon und das
erinnert an die dunkelsten
unserer Geschichte und wir sind nicht
nervös die einzigen die nervös sind das
sind sie und die SPD vor allem wenn ich
an die Wahlen dieses Jahr in Deutschland
denke an die Europawahl an die
Landtagswahl in Sachsen brandenbrurck
und Thüringen sie bekommen die Quittung
und zwar vom Souverän vom deutschen
Bürger und darauf freue ich mich darauf
freue ich
mich hätten sie wirklich in dieser
ganzen Debatte und Kampagne mit
Korrektiv hätten sie diese Leute noch
mal recherchieren lassen bei kumex oder
bei nordstream da erwarten wir
Ergebnisse hier im Parlament die sie
immer noch schuldig geblieben sind wer
diese Terrorakte durchgeführt hat
genauso die Geldverschwendung und bei
diesen ganzen Problemen die kumex
verursacht hat in diesem Sinne meine
Damen und Herren Werte Kollegen sage ich
eins die deutsche Wirtschaft lebt von
den Exporten und guten wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen und wir als AFD werden da
uns dafür wieder einsetzen dass Deutsch
als Wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv ist
und dass Deutschland vor allen Dingen
endlich wieder das verdient was es hat
eine ordentliche und vernünftige
Regierung vielen
Dank als nächstes erhält das Wort
Andreas audretsch für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und
Herren in unserer Gesellschaft aber auch
in unseren Parlamenten auch hier bei uns
im Deutschen Bundestag sind Feinde
unserer Verfassung und wir haben es
glaube ich in zwei reden heute hier
gesehen in der Rede von Frau Weidel in
der Rede von Herrn krupaler Feinde
unserer liberalen Demokratie die die
apppfeiler unseres Grundgesetzes die
Freiheit und die it aller Menschen offen
in Frage
stellen wir haben viel über das Treffen
in Potzdam gehört es braucht gar nicht
nur das weil wir es auch ansonsten sehr
sehr offensichtlich auf dem Tisch haben
20 bis 30% der Bevölkerung will Björn
höcke aus dem Land schaffen so hat er es
im dezember 2023 gesagt die Videos sind
online jeder kann es sehen jeder kann es
wissen man möchte man muss es nur wissen
wollen und um den Kampf um unsere
Demokratie erfolgreich führen zu können
brauchen wir alle in diesem Land wir
brauchen als erstes brauchen wir starke
Sicherheitsbehörden die zu hinschauen
die die zuschauen was passiert und
dokumentieren was los ist wir brauchen
als zweites Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die herausarbeiten z.B
dass ihre Partei das Umfeld ihrer Partei
um konkret zu sein das Umfeld von
bertrix von Storch ganz konkret von
Russland finanziert wurde dreimal wurde
ich verklagt von dem Umfeld ihrer Partei
weil ich das offen sage dreimal haben
Gerichte es bestätigt dreimal haben sie
gesagt ich sage es zurecht ich sag's
hier noch mal sie das Umfeld ihrer
Partei wird finanziert von Oligarchen
aus Putins
Russland wir brauchen diese
Wissenschaftler wir brauchen aber auch
die freie Presse die aufdeckt was da los
ist bei Ihnen und dass sie genau das
hier wieder in Frage Gestellen zeigt wie
wichtig das ist wir brauchen die freie
Presse wenn sie sich mit rechtsextremen
treffen wenn Sie die Deportation von
Millionen von Menschen planen ganz
konkret durch deklinieren und wir
brauchen nicht zuletzt Hunderttausende
von Menschen auf den Straßen um sicher
zustellen dass sie nicht die
Deutungshoheit über unsere Gesellschaft
erlangen können deswegen bin ich so
dankbar über die Mitte der Gesellschaft
die sich aufgemacht hat genau das jetzt
auch ganz öffentlich deutlich zu machen
ich bin dankbar für 350 000 Menschen in
Berlin über 100.000 in Düsseldorf und in
Hamburg aber ich bin fast noch
beeindruckter
über 5000 Menschen in Düren über 4000
Menschen in Singen über 1500 Menschen in
saahlfeld über die 500 Menschen in
Luckenwalde über die 400 Menschen in
sprememberg all das sind Menschen die
ganz klar sagen wir stehen auf gegen
diesen Rechtsextremismus und dass sie es
jetzt versuchen als großstadtphänomen
als von der Regierung gesteuert
darzustellen zeigt wie viel Angst sie
haben zeigt wie nervös sie sind dass für
sie jeden Tag deutlicher wird dass das
nicht weiter akzeptiert wird und dass
jeden Tag deutlicher wird dass sie aufs
engste zusammenarbeiten rechtsextreme
identitäre Leute aus der AFD und ihre
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
zusammen am Tisch zusammen planend das
was dieses Land zu Grunde richten soll
das was wir heute morgen beklagt haben
was sie jetzt wieder ganz konkret planen
und ein zweiter Grund es gibt einen
zweiten Grund warum sie so nervös sind
weil eine These gebrochen wurde nämlich
dass die Rechtsextremen in diesem Land
die Mehrheit der Menschen stellen das
wollen sie weis machen das Gegenteil ist
bewiesen htausende gehen auf die Straße
um deutlich zu machen diese These trifft
nicht zu die Mehrheit unseres Landes
lehnt diesen Rechtsextremismus
entschieden
ab heute sagen wir nie
wieder und wer sagt nie wieder der muss
wissen was damals war das ist die
Voraussetzung
dafür deswegen haben wir heute an die
Greultaten des Nationalsozialismus
erinnert und deswegen sorgen wir mit
diesem Haushalt mit dem was wir tun dass
in ganz Deutschland stetig daran
erinnert werden kann wir haben bereits
im letzten Jahr ein großes Paket über 80
Millionen Euro gepackt um die
kzgedenkstätten in Deutschland stärker
zu unter stützen und wir haben jetzt in
diesem Haushalt noch mal nachgelegt noch
mal Geld zur Verfügung gestellt so haben
wir z.B die Gedenkstätten stätdte
deutscher Widerstand die Stiftung
Denkmal für die ermordeten Juden Europas
die Stiftung niedersächsische
gedenkstätdten Bergen Belsen und andere
mit noch mal knapp 2 Millionen Euro
gestärkt weil wir wissen wie notwendig
es ist dass sich Menschen in ganz
Deutschland mit diesen Fragen
auseinandersetzen und wir stärken mit
dem was wir machen kulturelles Leben in
ganz Deutschland mit dem Amateur
musikfond von der blas kabelle Kapelle
bis zum Musikfest in ganz Deutschland
mit dem Festival förderfond ebenfalls
wir unterstützen weiter das UNESCO
welterbezeche Zollverein weil uns diese
Geschichte wichtig ist die aufrecht
zuerhalten und gleichzeitig das Haus der
Kulturen der Welt und das Heimaten
Festival weil dort aufgearbeitet und
gezeigt wird dass es Heimat in
Deutschland gibt und zwar im Plural in
Vielfalt weil wir alle gemeinsam hier
zusammen leben danke
ihnen
Ban spricht jetzt für die FDP
Fraktion frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren eine haushaltspolitische
Debatte ist mehr als das Vortragen von
Zahlen das haben wir heute gesehen es
geht in erster Linie um die Politik die
dahinter steht und diese Politik muss
immer im Einklang mit der Realität im
Land sein und wie sieht diese Realität
aus wir haben enorme
wirtschaftspolitische Herausforderung
wir haben enorme finanzpolitische
Herausforderung in unserem Land das
Thema Migration wird uns noch eine ganze
Weile beschäftigen und wir haben
zentrale außen und sicherheitspolitische
Fragen die wir noch in diesem Jahr
beantworten müssen es ist schon mehrmals
heute angesprochen was passiert wenn wir
dieses Jahres oder Anfang nächsten
Jahres möglicherweise im Weißen Haus
einen anderen Präsidenten haben einen
Präsidenten der uns dann sagt
beispielsweise der Krieg in der Ukraine
kümmert euch liebe Europäer selbst liebe
Europäer kümmert euch selbst um die
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa das hat
ja nicht nur außen und
sicherheitspolitische folgen sondern
eine mögliche Präsidentschaft von Herrn
Trump hätte auch Handels und
wirtschaftspolitische folgen und
deswegen ist das auch außerordentlich
wichtig dass wir in Deutschland und
Europa auf diese Herausforderung
vorbereitet
sind wenn
wir wenn wir in dieser wirtschaftlich
schwierigen Situation ein starkes Land
bleiben wollen und den Wohlstand in
unserem Land bewahren und mehren wollen
dann müssen wir dringend den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland stärken
und Deutschland wieder fit für die
Zukunft machen der wirtschaftliche
Erfolg unseres Landes ist von zentraler
Bedeutung für unsere Zukunft me Damen
und Herren und ich will ihnen das auch
an dieser Stelle ganz klar sagen wer wer
ökologische Transformation will wer
funktionierende sich wer funktionierende
soziale Sicherungssysteme will muss die
Rahmenbedingung dafür schaffen dass die
Menschen Unternehmen und Betriebe in
unserem Land in erster Linie entlastet
werden und nicht belastet
werden vielleicht hat es der eine oder
andere in der Politik auch vergessen
aber wir erinnern gerne daran es muss
erst erwirtschaftet werden bevor
überhaupt verteilt werden kann meine
Damen und
Herren und ich will die Gelegenheit
nutzen um auch zu verdeutlichen wie
wichtig in diesem Zusammenhang eine
solide Finanzpolitik ist wir haben heute
Inflation im Euroraum wir haben eine
andere Zinsentwicklung als noch vor
einigen Jahren wir haben Krieg in Europa
wer in dieser schwierigen Situation eine
Schuldenpolitik will beschädigt den
Wirtschafts und Finanzstandort
Deutschland und macht einen großen
ler alles muss alles muss heutzutage in
Deutschland nachhaltig sein das ist auch
gut so aber erstaunlicherweise wird
gerne in der Politik vergessen dass auch
Finanzpolitik nachhaltig sein muss das
heißt keine Belastungen für für die
Zukunft und keine Schuldenpolitik auf
Kosten künftiger Generation meine Damen
und
Herren wir dürfen keine Ken keine
Schulden machen auf Kosten künftiger
Generation auf schuen keine Zukunft
bauen und er recht nicht die Krisen
dieser Zeit lösen und meine Damen und
Herren das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat
selbstverständlich einiges verändert
dieses Urteil bedeutet aber lieber Rolf
mützeen nicht nicht dass wir die
Schuldenbremse umgehen dieses Urteil
bedeutet auch nicht dass wir die
Schuldenbremse Schleifen sondern dieses
Urteil bedeutet dass wir die
Schuldenbremse in diesem Land Stärken
lieber Rolf und das ist die zentrale
Botschaft des
Urteils und ich will dir das auch ganz
klar sagen lieber Rolf weil wir uns auch
sehr lange kennen und dich auch sehr
schätze aber es ist schon bemerkenswert
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse steht
auch so im Koalitionsvertrag
gelegentlich ist es auch gut sich den
Koalitionsvertrag anzuschauen und sich
hier hinzustellen und einfach Herrn märz
ein Angebot zu machen über die Umgehung
der Schuldenbremse zu reden finde ich
bemerkenswert lieber
Rolf wir sind wir sind beide
reheinländer ich habe sehr viel
Verständnis für die Art des Humors hier
und von daher ist es alles in Ordnung
geschenkt alles geschenkt meine Damen
und Herren meine Damen und Herren ich
will ich will aber an dieser Stelle noch
mal eine Sache deutlich machen denn das
wird immer der Unterschied bleiben
zwischen uns wir haben ein anderes
Staatsverständnis als ihr und das ist
der Unterschied das ist der große
Unterschied für uns ist das Geld des
Steuer Steuerzahlers nicht eine
beliebige verteilungsmasse für uns ist
es übrigens auch nicht das Geld des
Staates sondern das Geld der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und das ist der große
Unterschied und wenn wir sagen solide
Finanzpolitik und wenn wir sagen solide
Finanzpolitik dann heißt es in erster
Linie Respekt vor der Leistung der
Steuerzahlerin und Steuerzahler in
diesem Land das muss auch gelegentlich
wieder in diesem Haus deutlicher gesagt
werden meine Damen und Herren der
nächste Haushalt wird kommen die
nächsten intensive Debatten stehen auch
vor der Tür wir werden uns für die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse einsetzen
und wir werden Steuererhöhungen
bekämpfen und vermeiden wir sind seit
vielen Jahren in Deutschland ein
hochsteuerland Ja wenn Sie mir das nicht
glauben ich kann Ihnen nur empfehlen
sich dort die die Tabellen der oscd
anzuschauen wir sind seit vielen Jahren
in Deutschland ein hochsteuerland in
diesem Land sind die Belastungen für die
Menschen für die Betriebe für die unter
ne außerordentlich hoch und wer in
dieser Situation eine Schuldenpolitik
macht macht nicht nur ein Fehler sondern
das ist gerade Gift für den
Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und ich will auch an der
Stelle noch einmal weil das ja auch eine
haushaltspolitische Debatte ist der
deutsche Staat hat keine
einnahmeprobleme das Problem sind die
Ausgaben meine Damen und Herren und da
müssen wir ran und wenn wir und wenn wir
über die Ausgaben reden dann müssen wir
selbstverständlich auch über das Thema
Haushaltskonsolidierung reden und ich
will euch noch eine Sache sagen wenn ich
schon hier vorne stehe wir werden auch
gemeinsam über die Zukunft des
Sozialstaates reden müssen denn das ist
eine zentrale Frage der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit in diesem Land der Moderne
funktionierende Sozialstaat darf nicht
nur gerecht sein gegenüber denjenigen
die die Hilfe brauchen sondern auch
gerecht sein gegenüber denjenigen die
die Hilfe finanzieren meine Damen und
Herren vielen Dank
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
will nur drauf hinweisen jetzt haben
alle mal irgendwie mehr oder weniger
eher mehr überzogen und wir haben ja
auch fleißig hier alles mögliche
abgezogen aber da nicht mehr so viele
Nachkommen werden wir jetzt sehr genau
auf die Redezeiten achten und ich bitte
Sie natürlich alle das auch zu tun und
die erste die das gleich unter Beweis
stellen kann ist Kirsten Radomski für
für die CDU CSU
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren nach den
außergewöhnlich langen parlamentarischen
Haushaltsberatungen debattieren wir
jetzt über den Einzelplan 04 der von der
Kultur über die
Integrationspolitik bis zu den
anliegenden Vertriebenen und den
Aufgaben des ostbeauftragten reicht im
Bereich der Kultur
bleibt die Filmförderung ein
Sorgenkind die Filmindustrie fordert
seit 2022 eine dringend benötigte und
zudem versprochene Reform aber statt
eine Reform in Angriff zu nehmen wird
weiterhin an Symbolpolitik festgehalten
wie dem sogenannten green culture diese
Fokussierung auf symbolische Maßnahmen
lenkt von den eigentlichen
Herausforderung ab die der
Kulturstandort Deutschland gegenwärtig
zu bewältigen hat
der erste Leitfaden aus dem Green
culture desk zur Theaterproduktion zeigt
bereits was Betreiber von Theaterbauten
technisch empfohlen wird es wird
empfohlen auf Bewegungsmelder und
Zeitschalter für die Beleuchtung
umzusteigen bei Wärmepumpen soll auf
Luftwärmepumpen anstatt
Erdwärmepumpen umgestallt werden das
Dach soll begrünt werden Regenwasser
soll aufgefangen werden und auf
kondensationswasser soll geachtet werden
diese technischen Maßnahmen sind
sicherlich gut im Baubereich aufgehoben
aber sie haben tatsächlich überhaupt
nichts mit Kultur im engeren Sinne zu
tun und das große Ziel dieser
Regulierung scheint der gesamte
kulturelle Sektor zu sein wir haben
daher gefordert dass der Ansatz green
culture desk bei der Staatsministerin
gestrichen wird die Koalition hat das
abgelehnt nun zur Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Migration flcht ine
und Integration sowie
Antirassismus die Vielfalt ihrer
Aufgabenbereiche ist beeindruckend und
beeindruckend sind auch die Ausgaben für
die
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
750.000 € für das kommende Jahr und nach
eigenen Angaben hat die Staatsministerin
im
Jahr 23 40% dieser Mittel für Social
Media Aktivitäten
genutzt schaut man sich das einmal
genauer an stellt man fest zwei bis drei
Posts pro Woche sind glaube ich eine
eher unterdurchschnittliche
Aktivität
auch es geht noch weiter auch bei der
Pressearbeit kann man die
Staatsministerin als eher mäßig aktiv
bezeichnen mit einer bis maximal zwei
Pressemitteilungen pro Monat im letzten
halben Jahr das und das bei einer
Staatsministerin die einen so wichtigen
und umfassenden Aufgabenbereich betreut
im Dezember fällt dann eine
Pressemitteilung mit dem Titel
kontrollquittung schafft mehr
Transparenz bei der Bundespolizei ins
Auge zur Erklärung für alle Anwesenden
künftig haben alle von der Bundespolizei
kontrollierten das Recht auf eine
sogenannte
kontrollquittung warum die Bundespolizei
kontrolliert beispielsweise in Zügen
Bahnhöfen oder an Flughäfen das schafft
nach Meinung der
Staatsministerin transparent gegen
rassistische Vorurteile und
Diskriminierung liebe Frau
Staatsministerin leider sind sie nicht
anwesend aber vielleicht können die
Kollegen aus dem Kanzleramt Ihnen das
mitteilen ich bin der Meinung dass
Rassismus
entschuldigung wo ist sie also schreien
sie doch nicht so rein die ist doch gar
nicht anwesend so ich bin der Meinung
dass Rassismus und Diskriminierung in
diesem Land keinen Platz haben dürfen
dieon gelobte kontrollquittung schafft
keine Transparenz sondern Bürokratie und
letzten Endes ein Misstrauen gegen die
Bundespolizei und wenn sie sich dann
auch noch rühmen eine wissenschaftliche
Evaluation für diese Maßnahme umgesetzt
zu haben dann muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen das ist schaufensterpitik der
Sonderklasse wenn Sie selbst am Ende der
pressemisteilung nämlich feststellen die
meisten kontrollen finden gar nicht
durch die Bundespolizei statt
sondern durch die
Landespolizei und kommen wir am Ende ich
muss mich ja Beilen frau Präsidentin zum
et des Bundeskanzlers der mit 200
Millionen angesetzt ist und allein davon
die Hälfte sind für den Erweiterungsbau
des Kanzleramtes vorgesehen wir gehen
genau wie der Bundesrechnungshof davon
aus dass dieses Geld nicht reichen wird
und haben die Bundesregierung
aufgefordert den Erweiterungsbau zu
stoppen leider hat die Mehrheit im
Ausschuss dieses abgelehnt
zusammenfassend stelle ich fest die
Legislaturperiode ist zur Hälfte vorbei
sie setzen falsche Prioritäten bei
Investitionen und Gesetzesentwürfen sie
haben den die Ernst der Lage nicht
erkannt deutschland braucht Reformen und
eine Bundesregierung die diese angeht
vielen
Dank nächster Redner ist für die SPD
Fraktion Achim post
ja ich gucke
[Gelächter]
mal ja Andi du traust mir einiges zu ne
also sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verhrten Damen und
Herren es ist gut dass wir in dieser
Woche den Haushalt beraten und
beschließen und es ist auch gut dass wir
in diesem Zusammenhang über unser Land
reden über Deutschland über die größte
Volkswirtschaft in
Europa in Zeiten von großen
Herausforderungen und wir tun das im
Jahr des 75 geburtstags des
Grundgesetzes der besten Verfassung die
wir in diesem Land je hatten und haben
und wir tun das
angesichts beeindruckender
Demonstrationen im ganzen Land
Demonstrationen der Kollege hat gesagt
derär für ein weltoffenes und
europäisches Deutschland wir tun das
angesichts von Demonstrationen der
Stärke die für Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt kämpfen und wenn ich mal
nach rechts nach ganz rechts in diesem
Hause gucke schauen Sie sich um in
diesem Land in kleinen und den großen
Städten im Norden im Süden und Westen
und im Osten das ist Deutschland das ist
unsere Demokratie das ist die Mehrheit
das ist die Mitte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und lassen Sie und lassen sie
uns lassen Sie uns über diese
haushaltswoche Reden liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zu jeder haushaltswoche zu
jeder Plenardebatte gehört auch Streit
das auch gut so inhaltlicher Streit
zugespitzter Streit aber zur Demokratie
gehört auch die zweite Seite der
Medaille nämlich Kompromiss und Konsens
und deshalb der Kollege märz ist gerade
nicht mehr da ich bin und bleibe
zuversichtlich liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dass wir da sie
auch dafür sind dass Wachstum in diesem
Land generiert wird ich bleibe
zuversichtlich dass wir was hinbekommen
beim Vermittlungsausschuss für das
wachstumschancengesetz wir sind gar
nicht so weit davon entfernt wir sind
gar nicht so weit davon entfernt einen
Kompromiss zu erzielen also ich setze
darauf dass sie vernünftig sind
vernünftig bleiben und auch hier alles
dafür tun dass wir Wachstum in
Deutschland ger Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen und ein zweiter Punkt sie sind
doch auch dafür dass die werrhafte
Demokratie gestärkt wird ich habe kein
Zweifel daran lassen sie un doch
zusammen darüber reden wie man das
höchste deutsche Gericht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht besser schützen
kann gegen Umtriebe von ganz rechts und
ich bin auch sicher dass sie da auch
nicht einfach Nein sagen werden sondern
sich genau überlegen ob sie mitmachen
oder nicht ich setze darauf dass Sie
mitmachen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir dabei sind wir alle
wollen starke Kommunen wir alle wollen
fähige Kommunen sie doch auch ich habe
gehört es gibt auch CDU Bürgermeister
und CDU Bürgermeisterin und auch in der
CSU gibt's viele bürgermeisterinn die
brauchen alle finanzielle Mittel deshalb
überlegen sie noch mal ganz genau ob sie
nicht mitmachchen wollen beim altschuenf
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wenn
wir über diesen Haushalt reden muss man
darüber reden dieser Haushalt gibt
Sicherheit
Investitionssicherheit
rekordinvestitionen von über 70
Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und dieser Haushalt organisiert
soziale Sicherheit und der
Arbeitsminister wird bald einen
Vorschlag machen um das Rentenniveau zu
stabilisieren und zwar über einen
längeren Zeitraum das ist gut für
Deutschland das ist gut für die
rentnerinen und Rentner und das ist auch
gut für dieses
Land
und kommen wir zu dem was ich vorhin
gehört habe von Seiten der AFD dass man
sich
überlegt vielleicht sogar mehr aus der
Europäischen Union auszutreten dexit ist
das Wort ich empfehle nur einmal ganz
kurz einen Blick nach
Großbritannien von allen Versprechungen
die diejenigen die das Land rausgeführt
haben aus der Europäischen Union es gäbe
mehr Wohlstand es gäbe ein stärkeres
Großbritannien es gebe mehr
Arbeitsplätze es gebe weniger Migranten
ist ein einziges versprechen ein
einziges in die Tat umgesetzt worden der
Pass ist wieder der Pass des Vereinigten
Königreiches der ist jetzt blau und
nicht mehr der Pass der Europäischen
Union der ist rot das ist das einzige
was sie umgesetzt haben und deshalb kann
ich nur sagen das ist ein Programm der
wohlstandsvernichtung der
arbeitsplatzvernichtung und würde
Deutschland in die Isolierung in
Deutschland und Europa und weltweit
führen liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
deshalb kann ich nur allen raten gucken
Sie genau hin was diese Partei
vorschlägt das geht so
nicht und letzter
Punkt ich bin
zuversichtlich sicher und zwar bei allen
demokratischen Parteien bei der
Regierung bei den ampelfraktionen und
auch bei der größten
Oppositionsfraktion dass wir in diesem
wichtigen Jahr 2024 in einem Jahr der
Entscheidungen alles dafür tun werden
dass die Demokratie und Menschenfeinde
verlieren und dass die wehrhafte die
lebendige die tolerante die liberale
Demokratie in Deutschland gewinnen wird
in diesem Sinne alles Gute schönen
Dank
der nächste Redner ist Martin Erwin
Renner für die AFD
[Applaus]
Fraktion ja hochverehrtes Präsidium ich
begrüße die demokratische Fraktion der
Alternative für Deutschland aber
natürlich auch alle anderen Fraktionen
hier im Hause vor allen die neue
sozialistische der Einheitspartei
Deutschlands die
nsed die sich hier so gerne als die
alleinigen Demokraten gerieren in
Wirklichkeit aber zu meist gegenteilig
handeln wir sprechen über den Haushalt
der Bundes Beauftragten für Kultur und
Medien der damalige Bundespräsident
Johannes Rau sagte im Mai 2003
richtigerweise wenn wir Kultur nur für
die Sahne auf dem Kuchen halten und
nicht für die Hefe im Teig dann
verstehen wir die Politik und unsere
Gesellschaft falsch der Mann hatte
Recht die Ampel und alle Parteien der
neuen Sozialistischen Einheitspartei
Deutschland verstehen unsere
Gesellschaft nicht nur falsch in
Wirklichkeit wollen sie eine neue
Gesellschaft mit dem neuen Menschen
schaffen ihre Politik bewirkt eine
Unkultur des Hasses der Entmenschlichung
und der Spaltung sie defieren eine
demokratische Oppositionspartei als
extremistische Rattenfänger und
entwürdigen damit auch deren Wähler zu
Ratten oder auch zu schmeifliegen die
sich auf einen
Haufen
verdauungsendprodukte versammeln das ist
doch ziemlich Strack so eine
Zuschreibung selbst für einen Zimmermann
oder Zwietracht Misstrauen Argwohn
Spaltung Bespitzelung und Verdächtigung
das ist die Saat der linksgrünen bolche
wen Kultur die auch mit den kulturetas
der vergangenen Jahre bestens
aufgewachsen ist nehmen wir exemplarisch
die chronisch linksdrehenden
schaktivisten von Korrektiv die wurden
im Jahre 2023 mit
600000 € aus der Staatskasse bezahlt
Bund und
NRW von diesem selbstnannten Medienhaus
hört man eigentlich nicht viel und
plötzlich kreieren Sie ein Spuk und
Gruselmärchen gegriffen und aufgebauscht
durch die klassischen Mädchen bisschen
framing bisschen was hinzuerfunden und
so weiter und die im Endstadium ihres
Niedergangs befindliche ampelregierung
dankte herzlich und rief sofort ihre
Steuergeld finanzierten
ökosozialistischen Apparatschik Apparate
zu Demonstrationen auf Horka wir haben
es gefunden den Stein der
weißen und wieder einmal das
Totalversagen der gebündel Mainstream
Medien die sich wie moralian mit dieser
Thematik beschäftigt haben der über
Jahrzehnte üpig gemess den linksapparat
der varia wuchert in immer größeren
Dimensionen und verteidigt so seine
errungene kulturelle Hegemonie in unsere
Gesellschaft sie haben sicher alle
Antonio grramschi gelesen der hat das
schon so beschrieben meine Damen und
Herren kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss ich
komm zum Schluss es ist hoch an der Zeit
dass alle dieseöter öpfe im
Bundeshaushalt gestrichen werden und wir
von der Alternative für Deutschland
werden die spülmeister sein alerta
alerta AFD ist
da die nächste Rednerin ist Dr Paula
pierkotta für bnus 90 die
grün
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen 2024 ist auch
das Jahr wichtiger Landtagswahl in
Ostdeutschland und deswegen steigt auch
gerade wieder die Frequenz steiler
Thesen zu Ostdeutschland in den
deutschen Politik Podcast die vielleicht
nicht normalerweise bekannt sind für die
größte
ostdeutschlandkpetenz und da gab's
neulich unter anderem so ein Satz im
Podcast Machtwechsel die Bundesregierung
versucht sich die Stimmen in
Ostdeutschland damit zu kaufen dass sie
den ostdeutschen teure Arbeitsplätze
hinstellt z.B in Magdeburg mit Intel
meine Damen und Herren nichts könnte
falscher sein und jeder der sowas
behauptet der hat sich weder mit
Ostdeutschland noch mit der
Notwendigkeit dieser strategischen
chipinvestitionen beschäftigt denn das
was ihn jeder Abgeordnete aus
Ostdeutschland der koalitionstragenden
Fraktion berichten wird können stimmen
kaaumann auch in Ostdeutschland für die
Demokratie nicht mit Mitteln aus dem
Bundeshaushalt sich einmal erkaufen aber
was man tatsächlich machen kann ist
anzuerkennen dass hier sich Magdeburg
und Dresden mit TSMC und Intel
durchgesetzt haben auch gegen
westdeutsche Standorte die sich beworben
haben und aufgrund der Verfügbarkeit z.B
von Flächen und den guten
Investitionsbedingungen von Ort sich
hier diese Standorte durchgesetzt haben
und die Bundesregierung das finanziert
weil es geostrategisch notwendig ist und
wer behauptet dass das wieder nur ein
subventionsgeschenk an ostdeutsche wäre
der verstätigt nicht nur Klischees
sondern der beleidigt und macht einmal
mehr ostdeutsche klein und das über 35
Jahre nach der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung und ich finde das
könnte jetzt wirklich mal zu Ende sein
auch in den großen deutschen Politik
Podcast meine Damen und
Herren was ihnen aber die Ostdeutschen
Abgeordneten der koalitionsrangen
Fraktion werden berichten können ist und
es erleben wir jeden Tag zu Hause bis in
die eigene Familie hinein da wo
Prosperität ist in Ostdeutschland da wo
zuzugstatt Wegzug stattfindet da ist
dann plötzlich auch nicht nur die
Lebenserwartung höher in Ostdeutschland
da sterben die Onkel auch in
Ostdeutschland nicht mit 65 am Herzen
Fakt wie in anderen Regionen
Ostdeutschlands noch viel zu oft sondern
da ist auch die Zufriedenheit mit der
gelebten Praxis der Demokratie plötzlich
höher und dass wir uns deswegen dafür
einsetzen auch mit dem Bittel des
Bundeshaushalts dass wir noch mehr
Regionen in Ostdeutschland haben die
prosperieren das ist nicht nur gerecht
angesichts der Geschichte das ist auch
die ureigenste Aufgabe jeder
Bundesregierung weil die Schaffung
gleichwertiger lebensverhältn ist die
Aufgabe jeder Bundesregierung und das
machen wir in diesem Bundeshaushalt
nicht nur mit Intel und TSMC nicht nur
mit der Unterstützung für Schwed und für
Leuner die wir übrigens jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal
gerettet haben auch für die Forschung an
regenerativen Kraftstoffen lieben Dank
SEB Müller auch für die gute
Zusammenarbeit an der Stelle aber nicht
zuletzt auch mit der Absicherung des
Kemnitzer wasserstoffstandorts mit
zusätzlichen Geldern fürs
zukunftszentrum in Halle für deutsche
Einheit und natürlich auch mit dem neuen
Standort für die dati in Erfurt das sind
alles Punkte wie wir neue Regionen in
Ostdeutschland zu prosperierenen reg
chen wen meine Damen und
Herren und das ist am Ende auch einfach
nur fair weil dieser Landesteil der
einfach so viel mehr Pech hatte als alle
anderen Landesteile und indem die
Bevölkerung jetzt noch Generationen
später für dieses Pech dieses Pech am
eigenen Leib spürt in Form von
niedrigerer Lebenserwartung in Form von
niedrigerem Wohlstand weil wir einfach
alle gemeinsam diese aufgab haben
Jahrzehnte später diese Ungleichheiten
endlich Stück für Stück abzubauen meine
Damen und Herren
es ist heute schon viel über die
aktuellen Demonstrationen gesagt worden
und wenn sie sich die Karte des
aktuellen demonstrationsgeschehens für
die starke Demokratie anschauen dann ist
das plötzlich eine der Karten wo sie die
ehemalige innerdeutsche Grenze nicht
mehr erkennen können und das ist neu das
ist neu selbst im Vergleich zu 2018 2018
sie erinnern sich die Ausschreitung in
chemnit Hase du bleibst hier da gab's
danach im September diese Demo wir sind
mehr in Chemnitz und da hat man es den
Leuten vor Ort noch nicht zugetraut dass
sie alleine genug Leute auf die Straße
kriegen da kamen Leute aus ganz
Deutschland vor allen Dingen auch Berlin
wir fuhren nach Chemnitz wir waren an
dem Tag mehr und am nächsten Tag waren
wir schon wieder nicht mehr mehr Leute
in Kemnitz und jetzt dem demonstrieren
die Leute in Kemnitz genauso wie in
Braunschweig in Leipzig genauso wie in
Essling und in Berlin genauso wie in
Hamburg weil wir auf der einen Seite
endlich in Westdeutschland akzeptieren
dass es kein ostdeutsches
regionalproblem ist die Demokratie zu
verteidigen und weil wir in
Ostdeutschland genug Menschen haben die
sich jetzt trauen auf die Straße zu
gehen da ist Deutschland wieder ein
Stück weiter zusammengewachsen in den
letzten 5 Jahren und es ist ein extrem
großer Grund zur Freude meine Damen und
Herren viele von uns fragen sich warum
müssen wir eigentlich dafür auf die
Straße gehen sollte es in diesem Land
selbst in dem Landesteil wo die
Demokratie nur nicht mal 40 Jahre alt
ist sollte es nicht selbstverständlich
sein dass in diesem Land niemals wieder
jemand auf die Straße gehen muss gegen
Parteien mit
deportationsfantasien und da kann man
das Gefühl haben dass man eigentlich
nicht hier auf der Straße stehen sollte
aber ich möchte noch mal dran ernern wir
können überhaupt nur auf der Straße
stehen wir können überhaupt nur für die
Demokratie demonstrieren weil in den
50ern in der alten Bundesrepublik
Menschen so klug und weise die
Demokratie aufgebaut haben und in
Ostdeutschland so mutig die SED Diktatur
zu Fall gebracht haben und deswegen ist
es auch ein großes Geschenk dass wir da
gemeinsam auf der Straße stehen können
und auch das kann einem ein besseres
Gefühl geben wenn wir diese
Demonstration jetzt in den nächsten
Monaten weitertragen in Ost und in West
vielen
Dank
und der nächste Redner ist Otto Fricke
für die FDP
Fraktion geschätzte frau Präsidentin und
Frau Kollegin pichotter und genau das
ist das dass das eben wie von Ihnen
beschrieben ist und das selbst wie ich
immer sage so ein ultra vessi wie ich
der vom linken nieder reinkommt an der
Stelle seinen Mitbürgern vorung sagen
kann seid weiter so neugierig
aufeinander und dann stellt ihr fest
dass bei allen Unterschieden ihr doch
gleicherweise deutsche Demokraten seid
das ist wichtig in unser Gesell das
müssen wir auch halten meine Damen und
Herren ich möchte dennoch als
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
versucht hat mit den beiden Kollegen
in dieser Koalition das hinzubekommen
und ich glaube es auch ganz kurz
hinbekommen hat noch mal auf ein paar
Dinge hinweisen bei diesem Haushalt der
zeigt was diese Koalition schaffen kann
wenn sie ja sich weniger streitet und
wenn sie am Ende nach schwierigen
Vorgaben Lösung findet wir halten die
Schuldenbremse ein wir setzen die
Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichtes um die
Investitionsquote ist auf Rekordhöhe in
der letzten 10 Jahre wir sorgen sowohl
dafür dass die natoquote mit 2,1%
eingehalten wird wir sorgen dafür dass
bei der Entwicklungshilfe wir mit 0,63%
weit über dem EU-Durchschnitt sind weit
über dem was vergleichbare Länder machen
ja ich weiß da gibt es Leute die sagen
mich interessiert nicht was in anderen
Ländern passiert aber ich glaube wer in
dieser Zeit noch national alleine denkt
er muss auch aber national alleine denkt
der wird am Ende auch alleine bleiben
meine Damen und Herren wir bauen
Sondervermögen ab wir sorgen dafür an
der Stelle dass das was ab baut wird
integriert wird in den Haushalt wir
helfen den Menschen im Aral trotz der
Tatsache dass uns das Verfassungsgericht
nicht mehr die Möglichkeit gibt wir
stoppen den personalaufwuchs übrigens
zum ersten Mal seit 2013 ein schelmwerer
böses dabei denkt dass das an der FDP
liegt wir halten dabei zugleich das
soziale Niveau an der Stelle wir sorgen
aber auch gleichzeitig dafür dass
diejenigen die sich verweigern
entsprechend auch Konsequenzen fühlen
müssen all das tut diese Koalition
zugleich singt noch das sage ich mit
Freude darf ich mit Freude sagen die
Steuerquote und bei alle dem wird immer
gesagt aber bei euch selber macht er
nichts und da gebe ich den kleinen
kurzen Hinweis nur bei den
besucherfahrten die uns allen sehr
wichtig sind und die ja übrigens
zugleich eine Vermittlung von Demokratie
sind hat der Bundestag dann aber auch
gesagt ja wir kürzen bei uns zweieinhalb
Millionen und bei den besucherfahrten
des Bundesrates die übrigens nicht die
Länder bezahlen sondern die der Bund
bezahlt kürzen wir auch um einhb das
heißt ja mag klein sein aber wir haben
auch immer geguckt wo betrifft es uns an
der Stelle und ich sage das auch
deutlich in dem nächsten Bundestag der
in dann etwas mehr als na ja z Jahren
wer weiß mal gucken wie sich das alles
darstellt
kleiner sein wird werden wir auch dann
noch mal an der Frage ein wenig sparen
aber woran wir nicht sparen werden ist
an der Demokratie denn is sie ist die
Basis dessen warum dieses Land mitten in
Europa funktionieren kann und Demokratie
ist etwas und da komme ich dann zur CDU
CSU deren Fraktionsvorsitzender nicht
mehr da ist der ein zuständiger
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitz für
den Haushalt nicht mehr da ist ah der ST
nein ich meine ich meine nicht den CSU
Kollegen ich meine schon den denjenigen
der hier als Herr Middelberg uns erklärt
hat wir würden nicht sparen ich will als
erstes der CDU CSU doch mal sagen
Demokratie ist Diskurs Demokratie ist
streiten um die besseren Lösungen und
wenn hier gesagt wird von ihrem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden wir würden die
Anträge ablehnen die Grünen haben letzte
Legislatur über 1500 Anträge im
Haushaltsausschuss gestellt wir über
2000 sie haben die immer abgelehnt und
doch haben wir sie jedes Mal
wiedergestellt und wo sind wir dann
gelandet in der Regierung und da wollen
sie doch auch wieder hin und sie wollen
doch nicht in Wirklichkeit mit leerrheit
hinkommen um dann nachher zu sagen oh es
tut uns alles Leid wir sind zufällig
wieder an die Regierung gekommen wir
haben vieles versprochen aber ist
eigentlich alles ganz anders eine solche
Opposition funktioniert nicht und dann
wird gesagt dann wird gesagt sie würden
sparen ich werde das am Freitag noch mal
ausführen die ganze Liste ihrer Leute
die das alles nicht darstellen ich
bleibe bei Ihnen bei dem Schweigen bei
Hamlet erster Aufzug zweite szenene doch
brich mein Herz den schweigen muss me m
das tat Hamlet kund weil er nicht nach
Wittenberg gehen konnte herzlichen
Dank und der nächste Redner ist für die
CDU CSU Fraktion se
Müller sehr gete frau Präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren mit dem
Bundeskanzler et debattieren wir auch
über den et des ostbeauftragten warum
eigentlich Ost und West weil der Osten
Deutschland noch strukturelle Probleme
hat und da möchte ich mit einem Wort des
Dankes beginnen ein Wort des Dankes an
die berichterstat des
Haushaltsausschusses dass sie die
Möglichkeit gegeben haben dass die
schipfabriken in tresden und Magdeburg
kommen und unter anderem die Möglichkeit
gegeben haben dass in Leuna demnächst
grüner Treibstoff für Flugzeuge
hergestellt wird herzlichen Dank
dafür und der Wort ein Wort des Dankes
hilt natürlich auch dass das
transformationszentrum auf den Weg
gebracht wird lieber Staatsminister
Schneider gewünscht hätten wir uns
natürlich am Anfang erst eine Debatte
über den Inhalt und dann über den
Architekturwettbewerb ich nehme aber
wohlwollend zur Kenntnis dass am 13 märz
im Kulturausschuss über das
transformationszentrum sich unterhalten
wird und dann natürlich über den Inhalt
des transformationszentrums miteinander
gerungen wird das ist ein gutes Signal
und eine herzliche Einladung an alle 84
Millionen Menschen hier in Deutschland
kommen sie in den Osten unserer blik
hier geht nicht nur die Sonne auf weil
wo wir sind es von und das werden wir in
den nächsten Jahren auch
beweisen und da meine Redezeit knapp ist
möchte ich trotzdem noch ein Dank das
Wort ein Dankeswort sagen an den
Bundesrat der heute bedauerlicherweise
nicht mehr so gut vertreten ist denn der
Bundesrat hat eine
repräsentationslücke geschlossen
ostdeutsche sind in führungsriegen zu
wenig repräsentiert und der Bundesrat
hat bei der Besetzung einer
verfassungsrichterstelle jemanden
eingesetzt und ernannt und gewählt der
an Karl markstadt geboren wurde und das
erhöht die Repräsentanz von ostdeutschen
und das ist so wichtig dass wir
miteinander zusammenwachsen herzlichen
Dank an den
Bundesrat aber natürlich gibt es auch
Themen und das wäre ja zu schade nur
Danke zu sagen wo man auch die Regierung
kritisieren muss weil es zu lange dauert
und lieber Karsten Schneider ich würde
mir ein wenig mehr eran wünschen bei dem
Thema Ratifizierung des Geld für die
Pipeline von für Schwed von Rostock nach
Schwed soll Geld fließen dieses Geld
muss ratifiziert werden Schwed muss
ausgelastet werden unser Vorschlag ist
sogar noch weitergehender wir brauchen
eine zweite Pipeline deswegen bisschen
mehr dreif mit und diesen dreif
mitnehmen damit auch die Kohle und
Strukturmittel gleich retifiziert werden
damit wir vor der Europawahl endlich
auch da ein positiven Haken hinter
machen können dass der Osten weiter
Wachstumsregion bleibt meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren und damit der
Osten weiter Wachstumsregion bleibt lass
ich mal andere für mich sprechen im
Bundeskanzleramt ist ein Brief
eingegangen der Industrie und
Handelskammern aus Ostdeutschland indem
Sie fehlende Einbindung verschiedener
Interessen in den politischen Prozess
bemängeln stattdessen machen sich
eklatante Unterschiede zwischen Worten
und Taten der Bundesregierung breit
heißt es in dem Brief als Beispiel
führten sie den erklar um den
Bundeshaushalt Ende 2023 an außerdem
kritisierten sie fehlenden
Bürokratieabbau und Anreize für
Nichtarbeit all dies führe dazu dass die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Deutschlands leide so alle alle
Industrie und Handelskammern in
Ostdeutschland und das sollte uns ein
wegruf sein ein wegruf VI in diesem Haus
denn das kleine flänzchen was sich
gerade zeigt ist auch bedroht bedroht
durch die Politik ihrer Koalition
deswegen rufe ich Ihnen von diesem Platz
aus und zu kehren sie endlich um beim
Planungsrecht das kostet kein Geld wenn
eine Ortsumfahrung wie in Rosslau seit
über 30 Jahren geplant wird und nicht
gebaut wird dann macht das nicht nur die
Menschen frustriert sondern es führt
auch zu kein Ergebnis kehren sie beim
Planungsrecht um kehren sie um beim
Thema Bürgergeld wir brauchen nicht
Bürgergeld wir brauchen Bürger in Arbeit
der Ministerpräsident aus Sachsen Anhalt
hat die Bürgerarbeit eingeführt 1
Million Menschen mehr in Arbeit aus
Bürgergeld entlastet unseren
Staatshaushalt und bringt zusätzliche
Einnahmen und insgesamt bis zu 30
Milliarden Euro kehren sie um beim
Bürgergeld kehren sie endlich um bei der
Energiewende es war ein Fehler die
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten diese hätten
nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg
weiterlaufen müssen kehren sie um bei
der Energiewende und kehren sie um beim
heizungsgesetz sie belasten insbesondere
den ländlichen Raum in Ostdeutschland wo
die durch wo das Durchschnittseinkommen
bei unter 40% liliegt kehren sie um beim
heizungsgesetz denn dann sind Sie auf
dem richtigen Weg ansonsten haben die
Menschen das Gegenmodell auf dem
Wahlzettel im Sommer diesen Jahres und
das ist die CDU CSU meine Damen und
Herren vielen
Dank und die nächste Rednerin ist für
die SPD Fraktion Sonja
[Applaus]
eichwede